passe-t-il hier on s'est régalé salut à
toi stouff on est reparti salut à tous
salut kevin bon bah c'est la ronde de et
hier ça a commencé de manière assez
assez chaude on peut le dire puisqu'il
ya eu déjà trois parties trois parties
décisives avec les victoires
respectivement ma de duda deux visites
et de mon petit chouchou du tournoi fin
de forest pas malheureux encore un petit
soft de gagner avec avec ce tout fin sa
veste ou fils il adore parier mais il
n'aime pas trop gagné 1 donc vraiment
l'important pour lui au niveau des paris
c'est de participer il l'a encore prouvé
hier et j'espère qu'il va reconduire sa
aujourd'hui avec son petit poulain
prague d'ananda il a choisi la petite
pépite mais on sait que c'est pas
forcément facile pour un tout jeune
comme ça d'être dans un tournoi avec
tous les monstres hier il a fait une
partie vraiment très intéressante contre
giry et on peut quand même dire se
trouve un petit mot aussi du challenger
où on a un représentant tricolore bas
peut-être le plus grand espoir
actuellement français puisque ses plus
jeunes grands maîtres de l'histoire de
france néanmoins il est dans un énorme
tournoi même s'il en a déjà fait des
énormes tournoi ben c'est pas c'est pas
si facile que ça hier avec les pièces
noires il a fait deux petites
imprécisions après avoir bien géré son
début de milieu de jeu et son ouverture
et malheureusement ça l'a conduit dans
une position difficile où il a où il a
craqué techniquement bon ben c'est le
baptême du feu de toute façon c'est pas
si facile sous fin sinon ça serait quoi
ouais maintenant puis là une position
finalement que dégaine pas si facile à
tenir en pratique avec avec 1,2
faiblesse
dont c'est la première partie on sait
que andrea généralement
est plutôt fort dans les fins de tournoi
j'ai envie de dire oui devant nous car
il a de la ressource et mentalement
c'est un monstre augmenté commente al
après + ben on en voulait c'est pas non
plus le dernier des abrutis et ouais
c'est ça en fait on a cité le sa
dernière nombre de grands maîtres vous
l'avez fait un retour canon mais le
plateau était quand même moins relevée
on va dire que les joueurs qui l'a battu
c'est des joueurs comme toi et moi à
quoi et du coup là il joue des des pros
ils jouent des pros
d'efforts grand maître expérimenté par
les plus forts de la planète mais dans
le challenger si on suit aussi on cite
gang ou leigh héroïne l'ami les joueurs
comme ça c'est pas facile à passer on
l'a bien vu hier ce sont des joueurs
très solides autour une grande
expérience donc pas facile tout
simplement on va pouvoir s'intéresser
aux confrontations de la honte d'eux je
sais que tu avais envie d'en parler se
trouve donc bah tu vas me dire il ya des
matches qui m'intéresse tout
particulièrement je crois alors surtout
un fan a surtout dû au fait vous
intéresse dans bon danser appariement
donc on voit clairement mon désarroi
simple francophonie scandé use donc ça
c'est un match le match point
intéressant mais ça c'est un peu le
match de fin de tableau
richard rapport 22 fort est hyper
intéressant les deux joueurs en plus de
2007 et et cérons de joueurs jeunes qui
promettent qu'ils sont des petits ont
des styles très originaux et j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup à les deux joueurs et
la base sans mettre à plat de la gombe
être un beau match ouais à prendre un
petit le petit prague donc mon bon
joueur on va dire favoris de la
compétition le tout jeune il allie la
peine 16 ans et il joue contre eux
contre un an sachant l'ancien chouchou
sur mon ancien chouchou donc moi je dois
vous dire je pense qu'il va exploser
avant 1-0 facile pour l'indien
ensuite on a 47 contre guiry match hyper
intéressant parce qu baccarat de celle
qui est bon le champion du monde le
joueur qui est largement favori jour
outre contre guiry qui est un genre qui
réussit pas forcément beaucoup beaucoup
à kara de celle sur qui est très solide
qui joue à domicile et et c'est le genre
qui ce troll beaucoup sur internet je
pense que dans la vraie vie ils sont
annie est en tout cas sur un vrai qui se
frite beaucoup donc c'est bon moi j'aime
beaucoup voir à chaque fois de plus du
tout c'est vraiment rigolo et donc ça
match rigolo pour en fait tout ce qui
est tweet là qui peut savoir que si guy
gagne il va y avoir un petit tweet sur
internet si 47 gagne il va me lancer un
tweet je pense enfin voilà des deux
côtés je pense que ça va partir donc on
est sur un résultat
le tenterait de joueurs bien sûr
mamediarov outils pimco et puis quand la
partie donc il va être motivé je pense
pour y aller aujourd'hui avec les pièces
blanches
objet de tenter quelque chose quoi en
plus bon maintenant je pense que vous
avez mais 40 scène joue pour 2009 100
lots donc donc
il faut bien deux parties quoi
du coup la pénurie hier oui et puis la
problématique vous le savez car ce n 6
bat et y'en a pas quelqu'un de son
niveau et gagne 5 points elo donc on va
dire que la victoire ça lui rapporte que
quatre points elo à peu près en moyenne
donc c'est long à l'histoire parce que
entre temps faut pas perdre donc le
record ça va ça va ça va être dur déjà
il pourrait penser battre son propre
vélo et après on verra et moi le mode ce
qui m'intéresse le plus c'est le match
des russes la carac in contre du golfe
alors je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant mais il ya eu enfin deux doubles
files travail pour l'équipe car 100
chocolat du monde donc à travailler
contre son compatriote nepomniachi
donc triste défaitiste du match
il ya eu beaucoup de demandes ire de de
critiques
1-2 carlson qui qualifia carmes ans et
un petit garçon avait déjà commencé
clairement un
critique est
officiellement sur internet tout ça
double offre pour avoir trahir son pays
et sa nation dans son joueur donc ces
carrières qui a critiqué lancé en
version qui a lancé le truc
moi je trouve après ces cinq à son avis
je défends tous enfin je comprends tout
y'a pas de soucis mais pour moi je
trouve que c'est complètement hors sujet
en fait parce que c'est un joueur contre
un joueur c'est pas un pays contre un
pays c'est bien sûr ces championnats du
monde c'était
c'était norvège compo russie inquiète
pas que nous que de beauf qui aurait
peut-être la russie là c'est un joueur
contre un joueur debove travail avec
arrêt kindle avec une épaule depuis déjà
de nombreuses années auparavant et avait
déjà accepté par les cartes cette année
là avant même de savoir que c'est une
époque il
ne pas le dire finalement non voilà bref
et en gros du coup moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec avec avec l'opinion
de caraquet dont je comprends et je je
respecte ce qu'ils sont encore avec
l'anaconda et pâtissiers sauf moi je
trouve que ces propos stupides voilà et
du coup en fait après ce titre c'est une
mentalité aussi particulièrement réussie
famille gayant la nation et du co bon
mais je suis complètement d'accord j'ai
enfin en bon français moi ça ne me
choque pas non plus comme tu l'as dit
c'est une compétition et individuelle
donc je partage mais je peux comprendre
en fait l'idée qu'ils ont derrière mais
c'est pas très sain c'est pas très sain
tout simplement ça c'est clair
yes et donc du couvent moi depuis
toujours là je peux te dire que
carradine je ne peux plus le voir
vraiment je suis arrivé à ce niveau là
et donc là je suis à 100% pour pour
craquer non
du boeuf et
la camarade nous dit tortue magique
c'est une sorte il ya toujours
des problèmes entre les joueurs de haut
niveau il ya des belles amitiés et il ya
aussi des histoires forcément parce que
ce sont des gros ego et
pour le coup dans le monde des échecs
qui a pas beaucoup de l'argent mais il y
en a quand même pas mal pour le très
très haut niveau et d'ailleurs c'est
super ça permet ça permet de médiatiser
de récompenser les joueurs qui le
méritent
maintenant
c'est assez logique dans tous les sports
il y à il ya ce genre de petites
histoires entre les meilleurs donc les
échecs les échecs n'échappe pas à cette
règle la bombe on est on est partis avec
eux on avait laissé la petite la petite
partie de magnus pour pour démarrer on
va peut-être mettre la caméra des
joueurs ça te va tous font manière
nuancée par la barbarie ouais alors je
vais m donc il va falloir je la trouve
parce que forcément ça change tous les
jours et du coup on voit que magnus il
s'est levé après son petit cavalier à 3
qui est une souligne un cavalier à 3
dans ce début là je sais que j'ai déjà
regardé mais je ne sais plus que ce que
l'on joue
tout simplement dans ce genre doit
j'avais déjà vu ce type de position
cornette le jouer avec les deux couleurs
aime tant que j'avais vu
c'est que le fou prend 1,3 ce n'est pas
un coup que très recommandée parce que
puis on prend ça donne un père de
foucauld blanc la colonne b et vous
savez que dans l'angle l'aise devant ses
positions en fait de deux d'anglais ou
de catalan et dans l'oeuf ou g2 tape
toujours sur la diagonale donc notamment
le pion aux 17es avec la trombe et un ca
m est le prix supplémentaires aideront à
des doublés à bien sûr mais on aurait la
part de fou cavaliers 1,5 les prem's
diagonale et il y aurait des belle
compensation
j'avais entendu des fois j'avais vu
d'ailleurs des possibilités avec validé
cette cavale et b6 pour aller défendre
le pur ses quatre places petit moment de
sa capture ex
est prévu des idées des idées cahier
sept
cavaliers à trois cavaliers b6
comment c'était oui parce que la ville
allait couler plus standard ces dames
c'est de damas quatre cavaliers 5
vraiment donc on voit karl semaine il
est déjà dans une semaine je pense que
c'est le quatrième coup théorique alors
je vous dis ça sans fil et à mais je
dirais que c'est vraiment là souligne et
je voyais je voyais bien aussi quand
même cette ligne là tu vois et il me
semblait que j'avais ça dans un fichier
ça se fait souvent de faire fou 17
pouces et six dans cette dans ce genre
de config parce que ce qu'on peut
expliquer dans la catalane ce exception
là peuvent se virer assez facilement
c'est à dire que imaginons
les blancs arriveraient à apprendre ce
pion là et les noirs à faire ces 5 en
fait on a l'impression qu'il ya un
équilibre structurel après les changes
massives des pions dsr ce qui peut
arriver dans la suite que je cite est en
fait un gros problème c'est le fou j'ai
deux contrôles poussés vite et ça c'est
l'idée fondamentale de la catalane sa
part n pas eu grand chose mais krainik a
fait sa carrière là-dessus et
du coup ben le fou j'ai 2 domine de fou
s'est vite on a beaucoup de mal à sortir
les pièces et souvent il ya un petit
plus qui naît de ce genre de position
donc non il ya eu fou prend à 3 ce qui
me semble être le mot clé en main se
trouve avec fu 17 pouces et 6 et après
je sais plus mais voilà après après faut
bien connaître je pense qu'à l'image de
l'icône est quand même très très bien
très très bien ce champ du système chez
moi et je pense pas que ce soit une
grosse surprise pour halliche de voir
cette position parce que carlson la
jouer notamment enfin je sais de type de
position contre mais contre des dépôts
dans ce match a perdu 11 donc rakkada
martinair bien nakatani même bien donc
il est au courant mais si manu jous ça
c'est qu'il a forcément une idée il va
pas faire nul avec les blancs
de marais donc voilà mais à la magnus ça
va être un petit plus non maintenant
vous voilà c'est ce qu'il aime bien et
on l'a vu hier dans les parties et
tsypko ici et essayer il ya plusieurs
joueurs hier qui ont joué assez assez
tranquille et ça peut marcher on a vu
qu'à roanne avait obtenu une belle
position à pousser c'est shankland qui
visitait avait été très ambitieux dans
le début mais finalement après la jouer
une finale et il la pousse elle a gagné
donc et caruana aurait pu gagner donc ça
marche cette stratégie qui est surtout
de ne pas prendre de risques avoir une
position qu'on appelle à deux résultats
ou si les noirs jouent bien voir
parfaitement y font nulle et
et si l'adversaire est imprécis balle et
blanc l'emportent voilà ce que ce que
les blancs on recherche dans le monde
moderne aux échecs voilà ce qu'ont ce
qu'on voit et on en profite pour dire à
salut à tous ceux qui nous ont rejoint
là dans le chat et n'hésitez pas à nous
poser des questions s'il ya des coups
qui vous paraissent bizarres et de jouer
le rôle de lanceur d'alert si sur un des
échiquiers ben il y a quelque chose
d'important qui se passe parce qu'on ne
peut pas tout surveiller en même temps
donc on aime bien que vous nous inciter
à aller sur différents et chic et bah je
pense qu'on va continuer le tour
d'ailleurs souffre d aller à laisser
partir si vous voulez voir des parties
en particulier un n'hésitez pas on
essaiera autant que possible alors ce
qu'on va regarder aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt des parties du tournoi principal
est aussi bien sur la partie de marc
andré a qui joue le tournoi
challenger
de d'aller regarder bah ouais le
tricolore du tournoi b puis c'est un
grand espoir de
des échecs français donc c'est super
d'aller le voir et sinon on va se
concentrer sur les grosses parties du
tournoi rats et si c'était incroyable
qui se passe dans le b sur notre
échiquier vous aideront à nous prévenir
et nous aussi on a le droit d'être
attentif et de est de vous inciter à
aller voir cela alors du coup car ça ne
guérit la catalane classique de karl
scène avec une petite surprise d'une
souligner mais c'est pas si étonnant car
c'est ni aime bien ça il aime bien jouer
des positions même réputés égal mais
avec des idées derrière et là ça va être
intéressant juste pour finir là-dessus
car scène vient de gagner le fou de
cases noires et il a ses pions qui sont
un peu des structures et on va dire ça
ok mais regardez le coup qui vient de
jouer directement à quatre pour faire
parler le fou c'est un qui va se poser
tes vraisemblablement à a3 parce que
quand vous avez gagné le fou de
l'adversaire sur une couleur noire bas
vous allez essayer de valoriser votre
propre fou de cases noires ce qu'on
appelle le jeu de couleurs voilà c'est
parti pour la prélocation stratégiques
ou est très logique alors tu nous as ai
dit ce que tu voulais aller voir prague
nalanda forcément cariat kimba wood est
directement quelque ou dans l'ordre
comme comme tu manques de soins alors
n'ya pas donc du coup ces visites
caruana voilà je leur mette cantons rpt
été renommé qui nous demande quand on
est dans le chat qui ne disent et
marocains qui arrivent sont toujours en
ouverture théorique pourtant
réfléchissent toujours au prochain coup
en fait nous les joueurs ont d'énormes
connaissance mais vous n'imaginez même
pas en fait et en fait l'idée y
réfléchissent je pense peut-être au
choix de quel plan quelle ouverture quel
schéma ils vont vouloir faire ou alors
par rapport à la préparation qu'ils ont
pu faire la veille essayer de se
remémorer un petit peu tout ça avant de
jouer et pour être sûrs d'eux ils ont
beaucoup de temps à la pendule ils vont
pas d'autres tempos et un joueur n'a pas
toujours une seule ligne dans son
répertoire la cocarde scène à chaque
coup eh bien il peut jouer déjà 3 4 ou
différent à chaque fois simplement c'est
ce qui est énorme à retenir malgré les
grandes connaissances
versèrent je crois comme je le disais
tantôt raid comme je vous le disais que
c'est seulement le quatrième coup
théorique de la catalane à ce moment là
bref on est déjà dans un chapitre et
ensuite il y a interrogé sur un soussou
chapitre si tu veux ton tout raid qui
n'a pas forcément regarder
la veille guiry du coup c'est quinzaine
qui a fait ce choix d'ouverture est
maintenant guéri doit se rappeler de
tout ce qu'il a étudié là dessus et s'il
a étudié hier mais il va se rappeler de
tous les coups très facilement si
c'était il ya plus longtemps il va se
rappeler des grandes idées généraliste
et il va retrouver sur l'échiquier
vraisemblablement les coûts et jusqu'à
ou pas ça on le verra on le verra plus
tard mais c'est extrêmement difficile et
sages tantôt est ce que vachier lagrave
en parler c'est que ok il arrive à
retenir une multitude de coups des
dizaines de milliers centaines de
milliers le problème c'est de voir les
nuances c'est à dire qu assez loin des
fois il peut y avoir à 3 et à chis deux
petits pions qui ont bougé d'une case et
ça paraît insignifiant et non ça change
tout il faudra aussi quand l'adversaire
va jouer un coup plutôt non théorique
pouvoir s'adapter est ce que quand je
m'adapte je joue plan classique qui va
détruire le coup un peu marginale ou
alors est-ce qu'il faut
contrer ce coût marginal en jouant tout
autre chose et mad et des fois c'est
c'est l'un des schémas des fois c'est
l'autre c'est pas facile de se décider
c'est pour ça que les joueurs
réfléchissent alors on arrive sur la
partie vidéo caruana et du coup on voit
que
le thème de la semi slave marche très
bien c'est l'ouverture que j'ai tiqué en
ce moment en plus se trouve donc je suis
bien content la majorité des élèves et
du coup on est encore dans le même
schéma qu'hier avec au début une numéro
3 mais associé adams et 2 on appelle ça
plutôt lentilles mais rend l'âme et rend
aux échecs c'est le fait de jouer food
et trois dans ses positions et souvent
le jeu noir c'est de jouer des français
4 foot france et 4 ont fait reboucher le
fou pour pouvoir faire b5 stouff vous
l'a expliqué hier on attaque le fou bon
il ya four b3 féodaux qui existent mais
le couple est d'habitude c'est fou
détroit et là il ya plusieurs façon de
jouer est fou besset est fou des 6 ou à
6 avec toujours la même idée c'est qu'on
va faire à un moment c'est 5 pour
contrer au centre et avoir un
développement assez sympa avec avec les
noirs on lâche le centre mais on a un
développement sympa et on attaque le
centre comme dans beaucoup d'ouverture
on donne le centre ben on en voit
derrière donc ça c'est vraiment si je ne
m'abuse quoi oui dimanche il ya une
partie il ya une partie qui avait été je
crois au tata steel il ya
maintenant quelques années peut-être si
cette danse a zappé le chorus peut-être
je sais pas de piquant parce que vous
avez un vent dans cet endroit où je sais
plus et c'était la partie c'était
un monde non blancs s'étaient aronian
allende
et je crois que genre les blancs donc à
nantes avait amené la version en b 4-1
puis en d4
et on a quand même fait ses cinq as oui
et
tu connais normalement
il ya des a3b 4 ça devait être comme ça
qu'il avait joué c'est ça ouais après je
sais plus comment ces thèmes il ya vu un
c 5 avec une grosse prépare et à rené la
hauteur du
ça peut il existe encore enfin il existe
est de moins en moins ça arrive de moins
en moins mais avec des grosses près pas
souvent c'est plutôt les blancs qui
arrive à planter une prépa et quand
c'est les noirs c'est vrai au niveau
stouff c'est assez incroyable
sur les schémas à 3 et 4 c'est souvent
le coup à cinq qui est joué pour faire
éclater le pion b4 parce que
effectivement le thème c5 comme le
disait stouff du coup il faudrait
retrouver cette partie il ya peut-être
des personnes le chat qui vont aller se
jeter sur la référence que tu as donné
pour la proposer souffre c'est toujours
possible
en tout cas on voit que ça a pas mal
avancé dans pas mal de parties et on ira
voir il ya nice qui nous disait que
cariat kindu bof ça avait avancé très
vite mais ce sont deux excellents
théoricien donc c'est pas si étonnant
qu'ils soient au 16e et là on est dans
cette position là bas ça avancer très
vite dans cette intime et rend nos fous
des six ça permet potentiellement sur un
coup comme fou détroit de retrouver
l'âme et rang avec dépensé 4 et surtout
des 3 il y eu petit rock une variante un
peu plus marginale petit rock et e5 une
variante assez plate parce que ça peut
amener déjà un peu isolé exemple ses
promesses et prend des pions prend 1,5
et il y aura un pur isolé noir c'est
parce que les blancs choisi ici il sera
en ligne avec le cap il n'y a pas une
idée juste avec cd et cd et le cap si
bien sûr parce que on voit que la
position est quasiment symétrique après
1,4 qui a été joué dans la partie et on
peut voir que le cavalier bd c'est jane
le fou c'est 8 alors que moi mon
cavalier sur sa super 15 ont ces
trois-là gaz naturel et en plus en plus
pardon j'ai ma dame en c2 donc la
position est vraiment beaucoup plus
agréable j'ai un tempo de +2 tempo de
plus avec l'idée d'avoir le trait est
mon adversaire a fait au 6e 5 en deux
coups et moi j'ai fait trois quatre
aussi en deux coups mais le fait que
j'aie mon cavalier en c3 plus un tempo
de plus c'est une position plus agréable
pour les blancs visuellement sauf que ça
a été préparé et la caruana annonce avis
dit tu n'as rien on voit maintenant
bientôt faire nul voila voilà ce qu'il
annonce parce que dans cette position
les noirs n'espère pas grand chose de
mieux que le nul pour le moment en tout
cas puisqu'on voit que ben les blancs
c'est une position quasi symétriques
avec un meilleur développement donc il
est clair que vital avantage mais
caruana ils allaient noire et dit qu'il
va faire mieux extrêmement facilement
dans cette position donc lé pa lé pa
rigolote pour l'instant la partie à
moins que visiter trouver une nouvelle
idée ça ce n'est pour la part même
partie képi cenco carlson hier je vois
bien une nulle relate
est généralement cantal et noir
par exemple points d'écart à ce
niveau-là cantal et noir du vin était ok
pour la nulle pa généralement
généralement il va pas trop de problèmes
genre ici caruana il est au gouvernail
pas dans cette position après si bien
sûr vide ben exagère 3 d'ailleurs non
méconnaît cette position je pense mais à
voir les noirs c'est ses fins
généralement ce niveau là quand elle est
noire toujours un nul déjà que le
problème c'est que fabiano il allume une
heure 44 donc ça veut dire qu'il n'a pas
encore consommée il à gagner du temps
par rapport au temps initial s'il a
démarré avec une heure 40 et 30 secondes
donc du coup là il connaît tous par
coeur je suis pas forcément inquiet pour
le moment pour lui avoir
des fois on a des surprises mais là je
crois que non alors on continue
d'entourer tour des des échiquiers
alors bas comme on vous a parlé je vais
je vais rompre le tour je vais aller
voir carrier akin du beauf parce que
évidemment ça a énormément avancé on est
déjà en finale et on va regarder comment
comment cela est arrivé je vais vous
mettre vous mettre la petite gamme entre
cariat kingwell voilà ça joue très vite
eh
ben c'est possible que ça tu as fais là
s'est rapidement ouais parce qu'on a
accès aux précisions donc les joueurs
tournent à 99% de précisions donc là on
est dans une anglaise symétrique pour le
moment et elle va devenir moins
symétrique d'un coup puisque si ça a été
jouée à guider de faire un dessin rapide
il ya eu g3 est maintenant des cinq bons
du grand classique
la d4 c'est l'idée principale parce que
je vais poster mon fou en fils keto sur
le pion isolé puisque le coût des quatre
indique cela un futur bien isolés qu'à
et c6 les noirs accepte le pion isolé
mais veulent que soient les blancs qui
paie c'est à dire que sur des français
je peux sortir au moment mon fou et dans
ce cas là j'ai une petite concession de
la part des blancs pour qu'ils
obtiennent ce point isolé c'est pas à
moi de prendre en plus et de m le
cavalier ou alors il faut que j'ai une
excuse et regardez-les excuses devait
arriver fou j'ai deux élèves le fait
alors qu'est ce que ça change voilà
c'est intéressant de comprendre il veut
bien payer avec baignoire cavaliers
prends parce que derrière il a vu qu'il
pouvait redonner un coup de pied aux
cavaliers des cats pour éventuellement
ben qu'il y ait cavaliers français si
c'est bien français cissé les pions plus
d'eau pendant donc un coup de pied coups
de poing c'est du grand classique pour
l'instant on appelait ça l'initiative ou
la prise d'initiative aux échecs chaque
joueur se rend coup pour coup pour ne
pas perdre de temps fou b6 le fouet
comme bien placé maintenant en v6 et il
ya des idées d'avancé le pion isolé sein
des grands thèmes ce tous d'avancer le
plus isolé pour pour faire mal à
l'adversaire que ce pion deviennent
plutôt qu'une cible qui deviennent un
pion fort qui asphyxient un peu
l'adversaire
et ça c'est produit d'ailleurs assez
d'ailleurs juste pour expliquer
généralement quand un pion isolé enfin
caen caen toujours contre un pion isolé
qu'avec et blanc par exemple il faut
essayer autant que possible de bloquer
ses pions isolé pourquoi février pour
essai après d'aller de manger comme l'a
d'ailleurs au début voilà donc la sq il
met plus en d5 juste pouvoir
l'idée voilà essayer de mettre un pion
je sais pas un pur en a eu trois
cavaliers à eux de le fou en b2 voyez
avoir une position où vraiment on est
très solide sur le pion isolé pour
vaincre et un blocus et après au fur et
à mesure et essayer d'aller d'aller le
manger il est du coup les noirs doivent
empêcher tout ça et doivent essayer de
créer du comte roger être actif avec le
couffo c5 des noirs d'un j'attaque en
fait le cavalier des quatre donc je
propose déjà un échange cavaler
processes cavaler procès serait pas
forcément une très bonne idée pour les
blancs parce que du coup peut prendre
six viendrait défendre construit des
lampions des 5 et une fois que le
cavalier bouge bah je peux à plus je
veux plus tard jouer des 4 et le four à
y bien le four en b 6 par contre la
casse des quatre qui bloquent le pont
qui bloque le pion donc les blondes ont
vraiment du mal à installer quelqu'un en
d4 à la place ici jouer de 300 ya pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle parce que
je peux sentant manger en d4 avec
lecavalier et du coup on aurait implosé
de chacun donc cela poussera peu près
égale donc si les banques veulent jouer
pour un minimum davantage les banques
doivent essayer de garder le pion isolé
des rares et c'est de le manger donc
avec avel et b3 on voit que
le cavalier attaquions c5 et aussi les
blancs sont trois fois sur le sur le
pion des cinq des blancs et des noirs
donc le cavaliere 7,3 le fond orangé de
la demande d'être en d1 sont sur le pion
un pion
[Musique]
position de tonton est qui nous dit
mais pourquoi il n'a pas pris en fait
est là savent ça faisait partie d'une
préparation va vraisemblablement
de la part de du boeuf façon ils
connaissent après après faut aussi il ya
sans doute vrai vraiment du jeu puisque
ça fait partie de la prépa sas et ils
connaissent la position
il y avait les prendre d'impro
attaquez-vous 2 et rodez 8 qui arrive
vite voilà ça ça ça comme un 10 toof
très intéressant
on peut imaginer des coups comme
cavalier c3 et la dame 7 avait dû
peut-être avec tour des huit ça faisait
partie vous pouvez retrouver
vraisemblablement des parties sur le
sujet dans la base et du coup
et la dame des pins n'a pas trop de
casse vous allez parce que décrite comme
celui qu'avaient les b 4 en fait si tu
as des problèmes pratiques
toi t'as raison de vouloir prendre ce
pion des 5 hélas une préparation de très
haut niveau un peu style gambie il y
avait une initiative assez naturel pour
les noirs qui découlait de la prison des
5 donc on peut imaginer qu du beauf
connaissait déjà la position et il n'a
pas voulu se pare donc arias qui ne
connaissait déjà cette position et du
boeuf aussi d'ailleurs puisqu'il l'a
laissé et du coup il n'a pas voulu du
tout laisser cette possibilité au noir
qui après aurait pu jouer pour gagner du
coup la verrouiller un peu plus la
position avec petit rock les sanctions
avancée mais ça il le savait mais sur
décathlon est prévu cavaliers à quatre
cavaliers au bord cavaliers pas mort
qu'est ce que je peux rebondir là où l'a
donc ya pas de problème
du coup c'est vraiment sympa et
du coup pas pas de souci c'est normal
d'expliquer t vermenton te salue aussi
du coup oui bon voilà il ya vraiment pas
de pas de problème pas de problème dans
cette position le jeu ça va être
d'agresser le pion isolé quand même et
regardez il ya un flou g2 qui vit bien
donc petit rock quelle est l'urgence de
la position va sortir ce fou c1 c'est
très logique à chis maintenant il a
choisi et là il devait connaître là
encore cavaliers prend b6 apprend b6
pour
finalement sortir la tour c'est pour ça
qu'ils acceptent les pions les pions les
pions doublé des doublés par france et 6
alors là c'est une suite presque
théorique on peut imaginer soufia pas de
de gros problèmes avec le gain d'un pion
pour les blancs et là encore je suis
persuadé vu la rapidité des deux joueurs
que la position est connue un du boeuf
n'a pas dépensé un mois une seule minute
et tour des huit d'un premier spin
problème 6 alors je pense que vous êtes
assez choqué et on va pouvoir plutôt
expliquer cette position est léché le
dernier coup tous rêvent d un jouet par
par part car yakine stouff je te laisse
expliquer cette position
n'est pas si on l'aurait joué nous un
attention non faussée de préparation
donc ils ont des raisons de le faire i
ils ont ils n'ont pas trouvé ça c'est
sûr la chute hier ça c'est une position
qu'ils ont travaillé à la maison on est
d'accord donc du coup nous on apprend on
on n'est pas la position de moins donc
on va essayer de voir ce qui se passe
oui alors certes les noms une fois
qu'ils la mettent sous les yeux c'est
plus facile pour nous de d'expliquer
pourquoi
elle arrive ça c'est toujours pareil
mais par contre trouver ces coups-là etc
il est joué par les joueurs sont
préparés d'ailleurs ça continue à blitz
et bien sûr tu t'en prie donc là en fait
ici les blancs est un pion plus et
images et une structure de pions de noir
qui est un peu cassé avec les plans
double f 6
mai les normes beaucoup contre jeu
notamment sur la colonne à l'option à
deux le camel et b3 et en fait du coup
les gaz mangin que nous montre aussi
kevin on ne pense pas que rarement le
ténéré partie car quand j'ai aimé l'idée
c'est qu'en fait les noirs vont toujours
être actif et réussir à un super est
peut-être le pion à deux ou en tout cas
gagné
un initiative
auprès du coup ici on peut se rendre à
un coup comme moyen cavally 6 1 mais bon
j'ai pas facile mais par exemple d'un
coup comme cavalier e cap caval et des
cartes pardon
essayer de voir ce qu'on va manger
manger en a deux que la tour et
là il va y avoir des échanges massif
donc vous voyez par un cavalier des
quatre ans à deux cavaliers pour un fou
moi je dirais si on prend et peut-être
après d'arrière tour des six c'est de
manger tous les pions mais je prend b2
la presse peut aussi manger ce qu'ils
ont eu deux bref c'est le super arrêt
on va tous les pouvoirs tout échange et
puis ça va s'assurer de finale et tour
troisième contraction par exemple on
peut aussi je sais la décanale et des 4
prend à deux cadres et les professions
c6 plutôt prend b2 la captation chacun
j'ai un fou qui bien placé j'ai
l'implantation de hand et si ce bond
est en fait ici on va pas trop vraiment
comment les blancs pourraient prendre
vraiment un avantage
peut-être on décide d'abord mais je
prends à 2,5
sur une petite impression par exemple
dans le chatt briques cifta proposé
cavaliers des quatre ces cinq là ça
serait une faute faute manifeste désolé
pour toi mais comme ça tu vas tu vas
bien comprendre là je prend 1,6 puis on
prend à 3 et bah tu te retrouves avec un
pion de moi en finale et j'ai la seule
colonne de l'échiquier là qui me fait
bien plaisir qui va me permettre de
rentrer ma tour en dix-sept qu'on décide
d'ailleurs sur une des deux cases clé
pour ma tour soit hyper active donc là
les noirs ils ont en compensation du
pion de moins le fou est une belle
initiative sur a2 et b3 ce qui va nous
permettre comme nous l'expliqué stouff
de regagner le pion - en fait dans cette
position et
à ces cinq après tour des huit ces cinq
après tour des huit après tour des huit
ça doit être après tour d un
as ou alors c'était peut-être là ou
alors c'était peut-être là et dans ce
cas non c'est pas possible donc du coup
je sais pas tu t'es peut-être trompé de
cases où c'était dans une variante mais
en tout cas ce qu'on explique la de
manière assez assez simple c'est qu'il y
a les grosses compensation par contre du
boeuf bas il là il a vu avec leur dis
tout ça puisque il n'a pas encore
dépensé une minute c'est synonyme de
confiance pourquoi il bluffe pas en
réfléchissant un peu il a envie de
montrer ya deux manières de faire un
saut au bluff et on réfléchit un petit
peu pour faire semblant qu'on est pas
parfait au niveau des connaissances soit
andy à l'adversaire je connais tous et
on débite pour que car yakine voilà soit
un petit peu déboussolée et un peu deg
d'être tombé dans la préparation adverse
et on peut déjà dire que
vraisemblablement cette position elle
devrait faire nul il ya de bonnes
chances que du boeuf est très bien
préparée et c'est plutôt car yakine qui
a un léger plus mais sans doute pas
suffisant pour gagner voilà
mais en plus il ya un hybride entre les
deux quoi avec ses bas c'est donc je
pense que les acculant ses adducteurs
est bien à lui de montrer à brix et lyon
qu'avec les noirs j'écoutais une pompe
qui atteint voilà c'est bon tu vois je
pense qu'il a envie un petit peu de 2,2
le site c'est quoi
les brics yves-marie expliquer ce qu'il
voulait montrer s'ils voulaient voir
cavaliers des quatre est ce qu'il n'ya
pas tour des huit là mais je laissais
zingle dangereux de notre série mais je
crois que sur cavaliers des quatre
briques civ
alors je peux jouer tour des trois
autour des 2
[Musique]
si je fais tourner de la petite ah oui
oui c'est pas mal ça tour des données du
carrelet le d4 tour des huit tout autour
des 3 tu préfères tourne autour des 3
j'avais trouvé fous ces quatre
cavaliers processus
oui c'est ça oui tu as raison en fait
qu'elle est française 6 il faut pas se
faire avoir en fait je suis pas sûr sauf
que tu as raison ce que j'ai peut-être
fou prendre trois il faut horrible
horrible que nous on va regarder s'ils
n'ont pas vu au départ tu es très très
important le pas de bol tu sais c'est
toujours pareil à regarder ça c'est
marrant c'est grâce à brick siphon voix
c'est cette petite variante qui est qui
est ma foi assez rigolote tour des trois
souches j'hésitais entre tours d2 ou d3
les deux sont intéressants mais autour
des 3 laisse plus de souplesse puisque
la tour est protégée de dire directement
et en fait on regarde et fous ces quatre
pas clair du tout se trouve le plan de
calais processus que je n'ai pas vu au
départ et là bas je me dis bah qu'est ce
que je fais je me suis senti un peu bête
il ya peut-être vous prendrez trois cas
et prend des huit avec le culte iphone 4
sorti de nulle part puisque je contrôle
les cases du cavalier et attention aux
menaces vraiment venir le chercher donc
l'as tout va se dépêcher il va peut-être
tenté un une mission sauvetage la
mission sauvetage de ouf après la cabane
le bcap b5 le b 4 bce doit arriver
mission sociale et du coup sur b4 s'il
le joug stouff je fais b5 moi même
je ne sais pas la position ultra bizarre
voilà bon c'était un petit délire qu on
concevait mais oui tu as raison c'était
intéressant autour des 8 mai après tour
des 3c borderline de jouer comme ça si
tu veux les risques finalement sont
plutôt pris par les noirs parce qu'il
faut de faut déjà une grosse capacité
calculatoire pour aller dans la vente
qu'on était en train de citer agressive
et même tour des deux n'était pas si des
gueux que ça
il y avait plusieurs plusieurs idées mes
tours d2 bien sûr si on m'attaque si on
m'attaque lecavalier je peux je peux
repartir j'ai une petite idée assez
mignonne d'ailleurs sur tours d2 ces
cinq rubriques si j'avais prévu car
valiev trois tours prend cavaliers prend
et j'étais en train de regarder fou
prend 1 2s qu'on pouvait pas jouer b3
pour essayer d'en fermer le fou je pense
que ça suffit pas tout à fait sûr vous
prend 1 2 je voulais faire b3 et après
je rêvais hop voilà mais il ya encore
une mission sauvetage
vous connaissez un la mission sauvetage
maintenant avec b 5 c 4 peut-être des
cinq c4 de noir hu a repoussé un peu
comme fisher qu'il faut pour le fourrage
deux montants à deux c'est d'aller
sauver se fout des griffes du cavalier
mais comme la structure est pas beau pas
bonne peut-être c'est intéressant quand
vous voyez bon donc même dans la
position initiale était très très
compliqué mais bon je pense que ça
connaît et dès qu on n'a pas eu le coup
pour l'instant
cavalier ca et plus bizarres
visuellement mais pour moi c'est un coup
aussi un est d'ailleurs car yakine il en
pleine réflexion et cavaliers c1 ça
existe c'est pas en fait si vous voulez
pourquoi ça peut exister sans pêche les
tours 3 2 donc c'est pas ridicule du
tout on peut même imaginer les ventes
cas et c'est un fou prend 1,2 toujours
b3 et la bayorre encore une mission
sauvetage aujourd'hui c'est le thème
c'est la mission sauvetage avec fougue
et bien voilà fours b1 je repars
normalement dans ses positions préfère
avoir le fou vous savez la pression est
très ouverte il ya des pions sur les
deux ailes dôme le fou navigue plus vite
sauf que dans l'histoire les blancs ils
ont déjà obtenu
en plus du pion de plus qu'ils vont re
perd d'ailleurs une des faiblesses alain
le roy les blancs ne peuvent pas en
profiter tout de suite mais si la finale
s'éternise ça peut devenir des
faiblesses sur le long terme voilà un
peu la promesse des blancs qui sont ici
pour moi un peu mieux mais du boeuf et
dans sa préparation et sans doute que ce
n'est pas assez on embraye peut-être sur
une autre partie du coût alors moi je
moi je suis pour le 20 mai médias off
c'est intéressant ce qu'il a fait il
affine stouff
mamediarov film stouff et oui m'hamed
mamadi il a du cran m'hamed a fait aussi
du richard rapporte qu'en fait alors en
fait on peut citer mamediarov richard à
porte et souffre voilà voilà les jo
bavard je vais avoir n'oublie pas jo
bats va quand même ce serait un peu dur
pour lui voilà les les quatre les quatre
joueurs plein de créativité voilà qui
est donc il n'y a pas d'erreur
évidemment ya peut-être un cinquième
quelque part on pourrait trouver un
cinquième souffre est ce que tu as une
idée pour un cinquième il ya est morose
et beach avec morozevich qu'ils
pouvaient rentrer dans la catégorie de
joueurs fantasques et la mamediarov
a fait un truc incroyable je trouve
c'est vraiment c'est super donc et si
penco il joue s'anime zoo
est en fait il y balance une brique g4
et alors je peux vous dire qu'en tant
qu'entraîneur je me vante souvent
d'avoir une connaissance très large des
ouvertures mais pas assez profonde par
rapport à des joueurs de tout premier
plan eh ben pour être tout à fait je
n'ai jamais regardé j'ai quatre
peut-être que toi tu la regardes et est
ouf mais je n'ai jamais regardé par
contre je connaissais des quatre
cavaliers f6 g4 ça j'ai déjà vu dans les
ouvertures de blitz toof tu connais
peut-être ça aussi j'ai déjà vu en fait
à un gay ça on connaît oui il y avait
des princes quatre des cinq ans comme ça
voilà c'est ça c'est vraiment voilà
qu'arrive et prend l'idée j'obtiens tout
le centre et finalement les noirs
peuvent contrer avec des cinq protéger
leurs cavaliers c'est compliqué mais en
fait c'est un peu la même idée en mieux
du coup pas ce que je fais c'est cap
d'abord l'autre fait e6 du coup ils
protègent plus la cage g4 avec son fou
par transparence et du coup ils
balancent des cats il est fou hein
franchement ça fait plaisir mais pas fou
il a travaillé qu il a travaillé non
mais maintenant on voit on voit qu'il
est quand même beaucoup plus fantasques
mamediarov que mais il a souvent été
comme ça dont l avenir en quantité et le
blanc s'il bouge pas le pion g4 ou deux
pions 1 h 4
non mais c'est le mamediarov j'ai vu
deux fois je fais du monde c'est le mult
j'ai fait deux fois je vois du monde à
chaque fois il a gagné du coup c'est le
multiple champion du monde c'est
vraiment le joueur je les ai vu jouer il
s'amusait
très près du barrage ou d une 5 contre
toute la délégation azérie tous les
petits les enchaînés à la suite en
prenant une minute à la pendule c'est
vraiment un joueur un joueur génial et
du coup il envoie un gros g4 qu'on voit
quand même que les joueurs sont dans
l'idée de jouer pour le petit plus
surtout pas prendre de risques ça fait
plaisir quand même de voir ça à la
richard rapporte
j'aime beaucoup l'état d'esprit et
j'espère qu'elle va pas prendre une
caisse pour fêter ce à quoi donc des 5
qu'est ce que c'est parti en vrille
complet en plus
des cinq joueurs par cipango qui a
refusé en fait
de prendre angers 4 voyant que ce
n'était pas si facile on peut regarder
ce qui se passait sur cavaliers projet
car tu sais que c'est quoi l'idée l'idée
réel bon ici on a peut-être jeu dès le
iv avait l'air comestibles quand même
comme comme si on qu'est-ce qu'on
comprendrait par le cadre ça devait par
rapport à la lune principe alors moi je
sais pas ce que je connais rien mais
c'est généralement quand tu joues
revient au début avec des quatre avec
des 4 as te plaît attendez quelques uns
les tuent nous à nous faire cette étude
là c'est ça n'en fait juste des quatre
cavaliers f6
g4 cam à l'étranger quatre sur quatre
normalement on joue des cinq leaders du
fou c'est 8 qui s'activent sur le carry
gk part bien sûr voilà et du coup bon
après tu peux jouer 5 du coup j'ai des
cartes blanches bonnes choses dans la
partie ils n'auront je veux 6
ce qu'en disait et du tout mais le du
coup y'a plus vous prendrez 4 voilà il
ya plus le fou il soutiendra le cavalier
g4 donc peut-être qu'une idée
intéressante c'est que maintenant sur
kamal et pranger cadence elle lâche que
je veux 4 et ira plus des 5
c'est donc je regardais je regardais en
fait ce coup là je vais pas vous mentir
moi je veux faire le match du berger à
stouff
c'était c'était une idée pas aujourd'hui
ne te plus en fait si vous laissez pas
si crédit parce que je si vous voulez on
a de faire la blague du mas du berger
parce que je trouve ce qui est qu'il a
le combiné c'est pas sympa d'essayer de
profiter de quelqu'un de malade ça va
souvent fait on pas posé la question
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que j'ai
l'impression que tu es en train de
récupérer le rsa va me qui intégrait
manchots j'ai l'impression que je sais
pas aujourd'hui que je te planter le
match du berger
du coup vous voyez je me dis je défend
activement mon cavalier g4 et c'est la
prépa ce trépas de mamediarov ce qui
vous montre son fin c'est sûr
il a dû regarder des matchs 4 ou pas le
laisser de côté
dommage qu'à des coûts d'un 9,3 de
donges madame des fenêtres pour laisser
la casse pour le cavalier dégagé
et à une avance de développement assez
conséquente il vaut mieux bloquer le
fouet f1 parce qu'il a une case en g2
tout simplement et la position et les
super trippant tu vois là la préparation
de cinglés de mamediarov alors de cinglé
dans le sens complètement fantasque si
vous voulez on a l'impression qu'on voit
les petits plus tout le temps du jeu
classique au classique et là bas aucun
des deux joueurs n'a respecté les
principes on sait pas où ce roi va se
mettre
le centre appartient aux blancs les
noirs ils ont développé deux pièces sont
partis à la guerre avec seulement deux
pièces qu'il faut jamais faire bon voila
et mais ils ont un point de plus donc
les deux ont des excuses les deux ont
fait des concessions et c'est génial
comme parti quoi parce que on a
l'impression on aime voir ce genre de
partie parce qu'avec les ordinateurs on
a l'impression que c'est parti n'existe
plus alors qu'on en voyait à l'époque
dans entre les meilleurs joueurs du
monde et là il remet au goût du jour ce
côté un peu romantique du jeu d'échecs
et franchement c'est trippant c'est
trippant voilà et du coup je sais pas ce
que ce que ça vaut mais on reverra de
garder l'idée pour vos blitz ceux qui ne
savent pas que fois à faire contre
l'animent zoo malgé cat il veut gagner
contre 6,6 points communs mais hier
enfin
il sait qu'il était gagnant hier un
contre du beauf avec avec les noirs il a
décidé de faire des parties de folie
quoi c'est clair donc on va voir ce qui
s'est passé souffre maintenant
j'ai quatre des cinq il n'a pas voulu
aller dans la préparation d'un milliard
offre ici penco je pense je peux pas
savoir si vous voulez c'est un joueur
génial et cipango mais je pense qu'il ne
connaissait pas ce crew ou pas
suffisamment ce coup là parce que c'est
le genre de coups qu'on peut dénigrer
maintenant dans le monde des machines
la machine dit que c'est forcément
mauvais coups g4 donc il n'a pas
beaucoup étudié ou pas étudié du tout
donc il a préféré aller dans un jeu de
logique ils jouent des singles réaction
centrale et jeudi que bas sur g5 il peut
réagir toujours avec la réaction
centrale cavaliers à eux quatre ils
trouvé cette position un peu plus facile
à comprendre
vraisemblablement et c'est quand même
assez logique un surf ou g2 de jouer par
majorque à l'idée de jouer dans la
grotte par exemple quand il ya des
cartons je vous fous j'ai de très
rapidement donc c'est la case du fou et
surtout b4
qui est vraiment excellent parce que
comme les blancs essaie d'avancer vital
elles ont réagi au centre et là vous
voyez qu'un problème si je mets une
pièce en d2 le pion g5 va voler donc je
ne peux pas si je mets une pièce en c3
ne tombe donc le coût prévu par
mamediarov serwa f1 et je vous le dis je
suis certain que c'est sa préparation
donc c'est de la folie on peut se
demander d'ailleurs tout ce qui se
passait sur cavaliers pranger 5
en fait c'est juste logique je crois que
lecavalier g5 et bizarre et peut-être
qu'on continue de se développer par
cavalier c3 et qu'on considère le
cavalier la bise à ranger
53.44 donc lecavalier pourrait plus trop
venir à ces trois fours bkt ça doit
et je fais donc la composition qui est
censé être moins bonne pour les noirs
mais il ya des idées ya du jeu en
pratiquant tu connais pas super hugo je
pense pas qu'il y travaille il est venu
étudier normalement cette position chez
lui avec ses cris cible
aussi de cap a pas autant que vous-même
aide donc du coup c'est une intéressante
l'ordinateur et peut ne pas aimer mais
les gens ne sont pas des ordinateurs et
puis margairaz fils a étudié avec
l'ordinateur et la confronter ses idées
il s'est mis du côté noir et il a vu
qu'il avait des difficultés en tant que
genre humain vraisemblablement avec son
équipe de préparation et du coup bas
mais ils balancent ce truc fantasmes et
surtout b4 il dit lâche que le seul
cours ou en f1 l'adversaire peut
toujours prendre angers 5-1 là encore
sur cavaliers prend le v5 il faut
trouver des
et des idées un petit peu un petit peu
incroyable la pièce serait mal placé en
jeu à 5 1
du coup y'a h 4 c'est presque
enfermement
donc ici j'ai plusieurs j'ai plusieurs
idées peut-être damas quatre pour
provoquer un cavalier c6 peut-être h4
peut-être ces cinq pour enfermer le
fourbe et 4 du coup vous voyez une
prison qui ce qui peut se créer bref ya
pas mal d'idées avec avec les blancs ça
faisait partie de la préparation de mam
et diaraf et la position y perd rigolote
du coup et si penco une fois qu'ils
avaient fait donc provoqué le courroux
en f1 il a décidé sans doute à cause de
l'idée c'est 5 de ramener le fou ce qui
se fait souvent ils tapent le pion g5 et
ne peut plus se faire enfermer sont
fourbes et 4 ce qui était le risque dans
cette position et après ils te tuent
pour la caméra de bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr tu fais bien souffre au niveau de la
technique il faut toujours le rappeler à
l'ordre et si on l'a est-ce qu'on avait
mamediarov est-ce que vers il ya une
caméra poste et à laquelle et j'ai
l'impression que tu a tapé juste ouf
voilà je te mets la mlac la caméra que
tu voulais
on n'a pas de chance à douchez
intervient un bien qui me regardent le
mix gamme et ben on regarde regarde ce
que je t'ai mistoufle tu vas être ravis
et tu vas et oui tu vas lesur et
va trouver avec la cam donc on a toutes
les tables eh bien on est pour l'instant
sur les six penco parce que c'est le
joueur qui s'en douter le plus en
difficulté hier il avait une partie
tranquille et est maintenant mamediarov
lui propose une partie de folie une
partie de combattants donc franchement
on se régale on a de la en a de la
chance hein
c
c'est à yanis qui charrie emmely que et
qu'on devrait connaître stouff parce que
c'est le quinzième coule plus jouer g4
dans la position
et oui donc c'est très très très rare
très rare évidemment d'être confronté à
un g4 joué à nîmes zoo pendant très
longtemps jamais on m'a joué un coup
comme ça et bravo à main yves deroff
pour la tentative est franchement il a
de quoi être satisfait de cette
tentative de cette préparation un peu
fantasque puisqu'il a il a croqué 40
minutes à la pendule de son adversaire
ce qui est déjà beaucoup et il a une
position un peu dans le style des bughes
obama où on balance les pions de l'est
le roi hyper créative hyper ambitieuse
franchement ça promet c'est de partir et
d'ailleurs on a vu ici penco à la cam il
n'était pas une idée pas si serein
franchement on voyait qu'eux ils
n'étaient pas forcément content du
traquenard je pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui bosse comme un dingue ces ouvertures
et là il est sans filet débrouille toi
mon petit bonhomme lui dit mamediarov
parce que là il va voilà il va falloir
se creuser le cerveau il se creuse de
cerveau depuis g4 en fait depuis le
troisième coup c'est ultra rare et merci
dans le chat à ceux qui nous ont proposé
d'aller voir cette partie franchement
c'est génial c'est génial puisque sans
le vois vraiment pas tous les jours dans
ce monde du très très haut niveau aux
échecs et du coup c'est hyper
intéressant hyper content de voir cette
partie on va être obligé de continuer
notre petit tour mais franchement on va
surveiller et on vous laisse surveiller
cette partie aussi
puisqu'il ya c'était déjà le show avec
mamediarov contre du beauf voilà c'est
encore la partie chaude il ya une partie
hyper rigolote qu'on pourrait aller voir
si tu veux bon malheureusement c'est la
challenger on avait dit qu'on passerait
pas trop de temps là-dessus elle est
vraiment on fait des fantaisies nous
sommes tous phares allumés
et quand c'est donc un petit peu
originaux on est on est soit comme ça
notre excuse c'est qu'on va glisser
c'est à dire qu'on dira que c'est pour
aller voir marc andrieu rizzi et
affaiblissent et on glisse donc fait
nous glisser stouff donc on a prévu
d'aller ailleurs marc andrieu renzi
hélas hélas on glisse houston allons
voir marc andrieu et après on ira voir
la partie que je me j'aimerais bien que
la partie devant le fort est le frère
l'offre le frère on peut glisser
directement et après c'est promis on va
voir marc andry parce que parce que
marc-andré pour la sauce une position
relativement théorique ouais donc du
coup je préfère attendre un petit peu et
là on retrouve ganguly donc l'adversaire
qui a battu avec les blancs notre petite
pépite marc andré maury d'hier hegang où
lit on peut imaginer qu'il a planté une
préparation au frère de au petit frère
de john grant forest les deux frères
vont de forest en fait sont grand maître
et chaque et ils ont d'ailleurs une
petite soeur qui était très très
prometteuse je les ai vus en poussines
elles étaient 1800 donc aller je ferai
un petit pari là je dirais qu'elle est
au moins m féminin ça c'est quasiment
certain j'aimerais bien aller voir
l'info si quelqu'un a des infos de la
petite soeur vienne forest à combien à
combien elle et elle culmine et je crois
que ces matches qu'elle s'appelle
match-3 des je crois c'est pas un prénom
très court en bretagne donc
je peux pas dire avec exactitude stouff
mais ça doit être ça elle est combien
match elle développe
2189 voilà et elle est là pas de titre
n'a pas de sens encore macho mais elle a
levé le jeu est encore mais je pense
elle est née en 2007 elle est pas si
jeunes non plus hein
bon en fait elle va où elle peut encore
faire quoi oui peut être maître
international mixte a vraiment faim
allez dans ses standards là je pense
surtout que ça mange échec je pense à la
maison quand même avec avec les deux
frères donc le grand frère jordan donc
il ya plus de 2700
il a été champion d'europe jeunes ça
c'est sûr parce que je les ai vus être
champion d'europe
du coup c'est des purs star et lucas
donc
il joue dans un style sans compromis et
du coup on va voir il avait pourtant
fait une petit catalan comme
comme magnus voilà donc la catalane et
l'a20 une des variantes les plus
ambitieuses s'est dépensé 4 directement
avec derrière des cavaliers c6 a6b 5
bref c'est de croquer vite le pion c4
parce qu'on sait que le fou va aller en
g2 et après on essaie de s'attacher aux
pions s'écarte de s'accrocher et ça peut
ça peut bastonner fou j'ai deux ont peu
joué ces cinq rapide ça existe avec
l'idée de jouer qu'à et c6 très très
rapidement
donc petit rock cavaliers c6 c'est pour
ça que défendre voire cavaliers 5
indirectement donc là je pense que il
devait y devez connaître parce que
cavalier 5 c'est du grand classique je
crois que c'est toute la théorie pas de
problème fu 17
assez normal aussi de protéger celle ci
c'est d'empêcher l'ouverture de la
diagonale total là c'est la théorie pour
l'instant cavalier à 3 mais il ya dû
avoir une surprise qu'ils ont joué ils
ont joué invite tout ça c'est normal
jusque là il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas trop de surprises fawcett
salaire normal aussi c'est à dire que
l'urgence et de roque et parce que ça
s'envenime au centre si vous voulez donc
on a envie
ouais domaine l'euro à l'abri ça me
paraît logique d'un b3 rappelons ici que
les blancs ont un peu moins donc ils
doivent trouver l'initiative donc à
chaque fois ils vont faire des coups
piquante ap l'autre bam bam bam pour
pour envoyer je pense c'est logique 1
souffre d'un b3
et j'aime bien aussi laissé la souplesse
du fou pour le déterminer ben parce que
sa voilure jan skampa près d'homs et 7
et l'ail le détermine avec fo f4 logique
parce que la dame et ans et 7 il a eu un
indice de plus donc la garde et le fou
en c1 pour obtenir le maximum d'un 10 et
la dame en b3 c'était le coup naturel
qui piquait faut être quatre cahiers à
chaque fois qu'ils devaient connaître
tous à un stuff qu'en fait je passe là
c'est parti en cacahuète ouais donc du
coup cavaliers procès si ce
qu'est sylvain et que je les appelle les
ventes de supermarchés
je prends concret je prends tu prends et
on regarde avant normalement alors on va
regarder après mais normalement il faut
regarder avant
ouais ça a l'air bien compliqué basse
toof je vais laisser analysé en fait
j'ai déjà trop parlé je vais laisser
analyse et d'excès le bordel je laisse
tout fin ils adorent ça en plus le bazar
tous
ces c est tard compliquée elle a
évidemment on a on a parlé d'une pièce
comment le calvez les enjeux de baïla
pour fermer la pâte case sortie vous
voyez et le cavalier de cette île des
pins est dans le même cas il n'a pas de
case sortie en fait donc les cavaliers
enfin les deux cavaliers sont perdus et
enfin on en joue dans les bonnes
conditions donc n'est pas pressé de le
faire on a le temps de le faire vu
qu'ils sont tous les deux ans ferme et
wap range de et un coup il revoit
reprendre 7 et droit serait enfin le roi
noir serait
serait comment dire des rockets
d'ailleurs sûr je pense que je fais
c'est 6 d'abord que les dates the stuff
sur roues approche des cavaliers
français c'est ça le problème ah oui
pardon excuse moi j'peux pas du coup
ouais c'est ce que je voulais au début
mais si on apprend à cet ebook par damas
trois commandements qui peut être un
petit peu embêtant oui c'est ça c'est ce
que j'ai porte d'un bec à tous damas
trois donc en projet de
pascua on
est cinq à b5 peut-être
pessac à les bouger l'europe en dame
voilà des rencontres a dit un problème
si vous voulez on voit bien que va
prendre cette il ya d'un bec à tous
damas trois et nos droits n'a plus de
gaz on n'a pas forcément envie de le
mettre en relief 6 même si c'est
peut-être romantique est possible bon et
on n'a pas envie de le remettre en huit
ans qui atteint de découverte c'est
clair donc on va prendre cette on n'a
pas envie de le faire donc finalement
faut prendre deux temps d'abord on va
attaquer le cavalier pour qu'ils nous
fassent pas de mal par la suite comme ça
on pourra faire rois princes est
beaucoup plus tranquillement et sur un
échec on arrive à contrer donc ça c'est
l'idée avec bessin en fait c'est parce
qu'il a voulu jouer avec les blancs
d'abord après ça c'est ça c'est des
coups théorie qui son travail à la
maison ils ont pas ils jouent enfin
c'est pas nouveau pour eux donc c'est
pas si compliqué que ça pour eux parce
que ben
hilli potion qui connaissent qu'ils ont
des avis qui sont déjà analysés à la
maison c'est important de le dire
mais on ne connaît plus c'est ce qui a
dû se passer pour pour le petit luca
parce qu'à un moment on voit qu'il ya un
écart de temps qui s'est créé d'une demi
heure ce qui est beaucoup du coup jusque
là ça devait aller maman ça s'est gâté
ses entours c'est un salaire normal
le cavaillon en trois d'entre eux on
prend la colonne ces dames c5 rigolo de
la part de l'adversaire parce qu'on
reste en face du vis-à-vis mais il n'y a
pas de découverte possible et ça peut
nous permettre ce quoi de prendre de la
dame recettes soit de prendre du roi
sans se prendre de petites choses sur la
diagonale con dont on avait peur au
début souffre
alors dams et 5 dans le premier set
pourquoi prendre 7 et la partie est
totalement dingue n'y a pas de bonnes
découvertes en fait avec ce cavalier là
et d'un projet de on a une dame en fion
de kétou
chais pas vraiment quoi là on voit juste
rapidement quitte intermezzo du boeuf a
fait nul contre cardiaque in
china daily rien d'extraordinaire on
avait dit ce qu'ils avaient fait
rapide
on n'a pas été déçus du voyage voilà
parce qu'on voit c'est lé parti moderne
y en a qui le regrettent dans le chat on
a déjà eu la discussion là dessus
aujourd'hui les joueurs bien préparée
quand ils sont dans des positions
standard bas ça peut très vite s'aplatir
et est une partie
inintéressante et j'ai bien j'ai bien
aimé la comparaison d'hyères retrouve
dans le chat je regardais ça en main en
haut niveau du foot c'est comme voir un
triste 0-0 et
les
les personnes donc c'était michel et
yanis qui disent connaître ça et il y en
a un des deux qui a dit mais au moins au
moins on est au chaud en regardant les
échecs on va pas voir le 0-0 sur la
pelouse sous la pluie bon bah ça fait
partie du jeu d'une façon on peut rien
faire 1 souffre par rapport à ça on va
pas changer les règles
ça existe les nuls de combat ça fait
partie du jeu je pense qu'il ya rien à
faire puis bon en même temps s'ils
veulent gagner au bout d'un moment les
joueurs ce genre de tournois comme le
tata steel il va falloir l'emporter et
du coup bah ça ça peut arriver des
partis un peu plate et le lendemain ils
vont être agressive agressif pardon et à
la mamie ya enfin on a bien vu que
c'était possible ok cette position est
encore assez équilibrée au final
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup de choses mais finalement
les une position maintenant qu'il est à
peu près normale
le roi noir attend le 7 mai les cases
noires sont pas trop à exploiter pour
l'instant le fou en dix-sept va aller
bientôt
ses six exploiter les cases blanches
donc mais bon je retour du f3 un jour
donc sa position équilibrée assez égal
est-ce qu'on n'ira pas voir marc andré
un avantage de plus parce que j'ai eu la
réponse
la cheffe cats comme kiva dit que
c'était toutes les heures 6 minutes ok
on
fera ça sans problème juste j'ai eu la
question pourquoi il a joué fouet cette
des fois vous avez envie d'aller loin
avec vos pièces poussé 5-fu b4 mais déjà
attention parce que fout bécade vous
reprenez le retour de bâton déjà à 3 de
compal flint le fou ces sacs la pièce et
non protégées le se fout là va partir on
est d'accord je mène ma tour sur la
colonne ouverte et du coup tout on doit
être enfin c'est toi qui posait la
question bah tu vas te faire gênés en
fait donc des fois on va essayer d'avoir
un développement le plus agressif
possible et d'aller plutôt dans le camp
ennemi mais si serré dans le camp ennemi
pour se faire agresser autant rester
dans son propre camp et c'est ce que bon
vous vouliez à vue en plus il
connaissait la position donc c'est
toujours plus facile mais c'est souvent
une fois à niveau amateur quand vous
explique bas il faut être actif vous
avez dans le camp ennemi et vous prenez
vous prenez un coup de pied donc plutôt
que
que faire cela on reste on reste assez
modeste voilà on va les voir marc-andré
avant la page de pub marc-andré maori
dit bah c'est le même système on l'a vu
dans quelle partie ce système assez
way à ces cadeaux quand c'est non c'est
à dire
les huit des six le fameux l'un ouais
c'est un peu étonnant donc voilà on est
dans cinq candidats excusez moi granby
dame classique donc dans des vidéos que
s'il ya cette visite hier à québec ouais
c'est ça mais je suis vraiment un peu
étonné j'ai 4 h oui parce qu'en fait il
ya eu c d e des fous g5
et parfois f4 qu'on avait vu me semble
directement
il ya une partie aussi où il y avait eu
qu'à value8 que tu as cité avec fois f4
retour mais là où trois fous hausse est
d'accord tout est normal fou des trois
cabinets 7 dire je vous ai dit que le
plan que je conseillais un niveau
amateur c'était celui avec le cas
d'après avoir hockey parce qu'il est
très simple à jouer avec f3 d'abord pour
reconstruire le centre et avoir un
centre parfait il y a évidemment
d'autres plans qu'ils existent et il a
su h3 rapide qui est très joués 1 mais
pas aussi rapidement d'habitude c'est un
peu plus tard petit rock a été joué et
là je suis vraiment étonné là je ne
connais plus ce plan qui doit être un
plan modern age 3 petit rock et je
reviens f4
ouais alors je peux pas non plus tout
éclairer là dessus en kf2 nationaliste
mais
peut-être qu'ils vont toucher
l'équivalent de 4 le caveau de 4,5 aux
thématiques oui sans doute qu'en fait
d'en face et il a trouvé un système
autres c'est une préparation
vraisemblablement parce que c'est
impossible de jouer ça en partie sans
être préparés parce que c'est pas
naturel du tout si vous voulez
[Musique]
le jour soit celle ci l'adresse de oui
oui il a raison alors on va peut-être le
montrer à chaque en plus
à la place de à la place de de fouet de
faut être quatre si jamais la veille par
mme cavalier f3 je pense qu'il aime les
noirs ici aurait pas non plus faire le
bouquet value caf ouais c'est du
classique
quatre cavaliers 1,4 et du cou
les échanges massif profite du coup
plutôt au noir parce qu'on voit que le
développement blanc et très bons donc ça
pourrait leur permettre de faire des
attaques et là c'est un peu moins vrai
après un coup comme cavalcade qui se
base sur l'attaqué
en découverte du fou g5 et surtout
prendre dame prend on défend
suffisamment lecavalier 4 qui vient de
se poster ou alors l'alluré les
cavaliers 8 un peu comme hier aussi qui
sont jouables et cavaliers ou 4 est
quand même plus sympa humainement
parlant
ok rigolo donc du coup c'est vraiment
pour éviter ces variantes des changes de
pièces massif les blancs qui ont une
meilleure activité de caisse ne veulent
pas échange les pièces et fou et f4 ben
on est tranquille par rapport à ça il ya
plus le thème cavaliers de 4com 10 toof
donc on a on a trouvé la raison
cependant on peut se poser la question
il y aura toujours huit cavaliers fuite
vraisemblablement canton comme dans tout
ces variantes des changes et après
peut-être pourquoi pas le courroux des 6
ou cavaliers g6 donc on va voir est ce
qu'il y a une idée après
2 g4 ça peut se faire aussi de temps en
temps à la vie dit hier dans cette
position le centre est bloquée n'est pas
tout à fait fermée mais il est bloqué
bon bah plus petits partis qui va être
intéressant d'ailleurs ça a suivi 1 tour
8 cavaliers f3 et cavaliers en fuite
voilà et c'est un marc andrier de jouer
c'est un petit peu étonnant qu'il
réfléchisse parce que c'est lui qui a
décidé de jouer h trois fois f4 et j'ai
l'impression se trouve qu'on vient
d'assister à deux coups hyper naturel
que normalement il n'y a pas trop de
quoi être surpris
donc la cavalle g6 je pense doit être le
prochain voilà il va planquer son
fourrage de vraisemblablement parce
qu'il ne donnera pas contre le cavalier
sont fous de cases noires il attendra
food et 6 pour les changer après je suis
pas un spécialiste de la position mais
je sais que fin j'ai déjà vu beaucoup de
fois des coups comme cavalier 2,6 avec
lille est en fait de faire j'ai six
caves à l'est d'angers 7 et de mettre un
four à f/5 oui et forcer les plus casse
blanche en fait le fou
le fou ces huit c'était une mauvaise
pièce dans l'imposition vous voyez que
tous les cancres au classement je pense
que c'est le mauvais fou et de foot et 3
celle inverse les fouilles sont les
pions transgaz noir donc ce serait le
bon fourni trois échanges et c'est fou
serait intéressant et une manoeuvre avec
cavalier e 6 g 6 m kamali angers 7 entre
un ghetto et après aller changer les
foules ans je sais pas si c'est possible
ici mais je suis un socialiste connectés
mais j'ai joué cette ouverture est en
fait le plan donné par souffre on dit
que c'est le plan des anciennes il mais
il est revenu un petit un moment mais
maintenant à 15,3 je sais pas parce que
si tu es tout s'écoule a donc tout se
permet de faire des manoeuvres parce que
la position est assez figée ya pas d
évolution structurelle possible y'a pas
des ruptures facile à mettre en place
donc il a le droit
d'assurer le meilleur développement de
ces pièces d'aller chercher des
manoeuvres mais si tu fais tout ça
maintenant que j'ai joué mon tiens je
crois est ce que au bout du bout du
boucan toujours à kayes g7 est ce que
j'aurai droit comme g4 peut-être quand
même et du coup
ça me semble plutôt intéressant pour les
blancs si tu fais tout ça de jouer g4
carrément après peut-être que tu adores
ip avec la chance j'en sais rien mais je
dirai que c'est un peu long moi je vois
plutôt le plan un peu comme on l'a vu
hier des changes de pièces
moi ce que je verrai bien c'est petit
rock ici de marc-andré cavaliers g6
fouache 2 pour garder mon fou fou des
six derrière
j'accepte les échanges en prenant ou en
attendant qu'ils me prennent et je
commence mon plan d' attaques de
minorités que vous connaissez maintenant
on l'a déjà vu dans cette structure
carlsbad le plan de la taille d'une
minorité et si les noirs jouent à s'y
sont faits à quatre évidemment voilà
c'est à cinq là c'est un peu trop loin
mais on va réussir à faire baisser pour
tout péter suite au prochain épisode là
il ya deux plans avec les noirs qui vont
suivre bon bah c'est sympa ça promet en
tout cas on a une super entame
particulièrement la partie demain médias
rohff qu'on verra sûrement après la pub
est là dans la partie de marc andreu ça
va mettre un petit peu de temps à se
décanter forcément c'est une partie plus
positionnelle y est donc les gars on va
on va se payer quelques petits instants
comme une petite pub lab21 soumission
imposée par terre la main vous le savez
a donc poussé avec la salle vous allez
voir la salle du coup pendant la pub
voilà
elle a très vite les amis et je voudrais
pas avec grand plaisir allez à tout de
suite
[Musique]
m
vous
[Musique]
en
e
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
et on est repartis tous ensemble avec un
petit retour là on était sur la partie
de marc andré marie dit avant avant la
pause est
ce qu'on vous disait c'est ces produits
on avait
était faire un petit tour des stades un
petit tour des échiquiers et on disait
que cariat kiné du boeuf du boeuf avec
sorti une grosse prépa
ça s'annonce et un cellier égalisant et
visite un peu comme messi prennent comme
hier avait choisi une ouverture assez
plate on a on vous avait promis nul
assez rapide aussi donc avec fabiano
caruana et ça c'est fort logiquement
produit en fait il n'y a pas eu de
grosse surprise par rapport à ça du coup
on va pouvoir s'intéresser aux partis
qui vont beaucoup plus fight et donc
voilà vous avez vu la position de marc
andré marois dit
baky et prometteuse mais pour l'instant
le match n'est pas encore trop lancée
même si marc andré marois dit un petit
peu surpris son adversaire dans le début
d'ouverture donc ça va être assez
intéressant de devoir de voir cette
partie on va la suivre en tout cas sans
aucun sans aucun problème ça c'est
certain et il ya une petite suite quand
même on peut le dire mais rien
d'incroyable cavalier e 5 avait été joué
cavalier g6 et fou g3 le fait est que ça
pourrait permettre à stéphane peut-être
un f4 de la part de marc andrieu rizzi à
terme quoi ça c'est clair
avec la pollution équilibre pour
l'instant rien de rien d'extraordinaire
de crypter un petit plus blanc forcément
mais voilà il vous secoue de jouer c'est
c'est rien de spécial
est-ce qu'on pourrait aisément la partie
de petit con tre duda on n'a pas encore
vu on nous a demandé aussi on doit aller
voir prague amanda et on doit aller voir
aussi comment dirais-je la partie entre
entre richard rapporte et j'en passe
mais on va déjà les lois reprennent
honda je te spoile pas mais il se passe
pour l'instant pas grand chose à ta
sélection de mains entre eux entre deux
joueurs vraiment hyper tactique hyper
fantasque on aurait espéré une position
différente mais une partie différente
mais ok ok
[Musique]
on va voir de prague où la joie que les
caméras et oui lalla setti prague que 15
ans exactement il ya 15 ans et demi
ouais tout jeune tout jeunes grands
maîtres donc gros espoirs à wagner le
sarine chez les indiens
l'idéal serait vraiment plus que prague
et prague qu'il ya un an plus tôt google
voilà donc vraiment ces petites 16 15
donc on peut regarder comment on en est
arrivé là alors ça fait penser aux
positions de deux grandes fêtes sauf ce
que la grogne fait c'est un film qui est
au noir et on tape sur le centre donc là
on était au départ
dans un dans une potentielle ni mesure
indienne ou gambie dames on sait jamais
trop ce qui va être joué et sur
cavaliers 3 c'est pas ni la bogo ni la
west indienne qui ont été choisis mais
bien de gambie dame refusé et sur
cavaliers c3
relative
surprise avec cette idée de tarrach du
coup avec des positions qui en découlent
on pourrait se dire ça va être un pion
isoler et en fait non il ya eu cavaliers
prendrait 5 voilà avec le fait de
retrouver la structure zonneveld ici
quatre cavaliers français 3 puis en
français 3 voilà donc y avait beaucoup
de partis comme ça c'est devenu la mode
à un moment donné une pommade ou sac
noir pour égaliser
et j'ai notamment vu dans les parties de
nay du parti de bacrot aussi la clé dans
exactement est
donc bon on va voir
normalement c'est une variante plus tôt
pour jouer pour la nul avec les noirs
c'est à dire voilà on est
on égalise ici avec fougue et 4
d'ailleurs dans certaines positions on
peut jouer à des systèmes avec tourbe et
un camp là c'est comme s'il venait de
jouer cavalier f3000 ya aussi des
schémas que trop bien qu'ils existent
pour empêcher le fourbe et 4 là ce
n'était pas possible alors de coûts donc
faut b4 food et de on échange avec les
noirs c'est important de comprendre
cette structure les blancs ont tous le
centre donc je dois échangé avec
baignoire parce que je joue globalement
sur trois rangées donc si je veux pas me
retrouver asphyxié faut forcément que
j'échange des pièces ça va moins
valorisé le centre repris par les blancs
ici donc c'est ce que les noirs ont fait
ça fait partie du système souffre à un
rien d'étonnant
donc j'ai moins d espace donc je dois
changer péter noir c'est simplement
logique un exact gemon des traces
prouvent les pièces aux prises rock ou
c4 c4 l'urgence de la position qu'à
valider cette et rock aussi l'urgence de
la position b 6 d'urgence épouse iris et
souvent je tiens mon sens je vois pas
une tour qui était papa terrible fou
bessette maintenant celle là c'est ma
moins bonne pièce donc je m'en occupe
moins bonnes pièces pour les noirs donc
c'est très mécanique à vouvoyer tours à
huit donc pour ces huit four b3 chez un
peu triste de cette tour la
tour 8 ça évite de se prendre des
singles âge que ma tour prend part aux
combats en cas d'ouverture de la colonne
d'eau jusque là rien d'extraordinaire à
l'epo sur le banc des deux côtés les
gens sortent leurs pièces pris le sens
où est le petit plus blanc de
l'ouverture avec une position un peu
plus agréable un peu plus ambitieuse et
la regarder l'ascenseur tour 3 peut-être
un jour ça peut être
déjà une consolidation du centre avec
dame 2 mais aussi un éventuel passage où
l'ascenseur un ici cette petite
technique pour aller peut-être un jour
embêtait le roi noir on y est quand même
pas ici car valiyev six excellents vous
à 10,1 soyez jaloux du centre adverse
donc tapé lui sur la tronche ya pas il
n'y a pas d'autre mot a mais on y va un
tout faux on essaie de dégommer le
centre quand l'adversaire là où de le
disloquer grecque avant le 6 on provoque
5 par exemple vous gagnez la case des
sacs et le pion des cartes se retrouvent
arriérés donc
c'est quand même papa génial d'ongles à
prague il a voulu garder son centre
parfait avec cartes et des cats et qui
contrôle bien les cases contre le tout
il faut le garder parfait le plus
longtemps possible pour embêter
l'adversaire et là cavalier g4
duda béland bête un tour deux fois ci
s'y trouvent de l'activité et regarder
ce qu'on avait dit se produit donc là il
joue des coûts pour trouver l'initiative
et gêner l'adversaire et en vous
expliquer avec sauf qu'il faut il
changer les pièces agrainoirs regarder
on connaît ses classiques
noda il n'a pas beaucoup réfléchi déjà
dans la partie mais regardez un foot
français qu'à tours france et 4 dames 2
on est de plus en plus proche d'une
certaine égalité
donc d'aboudaou à la tour
parce que plus actif c'est logique
qu'elle aille là parce qu'elle est la
plus belle sans doute ou alors on
cherche à la protéger peut-être avec
avec dams et 7
parce que
ok en fait moi j'ai aussi une petite ado
minorité j'ai un pion à 1 contre ab et
je pourrais essayer d'être un jour de
faire face à massy s'élevant à 5 essais
de créer un point isolé en bessin je
trouve que qui est intéressant à bessens
kisses l'épave ans et je crois que c'est
ça que tu avais vu puisque je viens d'y
penser et du coup je me suis dit c'est
pas été pensée en disant faut valoriser
la majorité donc j'étais écouter tu vois
je trouve gb 5 à 4 je peux jouer web via
quatre peut-être
l'arctique montrent le peut-être des
cinq à quatre baies 5 harakat vous voyez
à bonds qui on prend complètement ajoie
parce que je donne une tour dans le no
mercy et tout reprendre son top ou mieux
parce que je fais rb5 large un pion
passer à 1000 un peu esseulé loin de la
dame est
la majorité centrale fait plus peur à
l'idée peut-être même dessin qui
pourrait arriver un jour donc c'est pas
si
c'est pas si facile quand même non on ne
peut pas dire
je trouve pas que ce soit si facile
forcément nous a joué
ok il ya un petit plus blanc et et ya
aucune faiblesse et blanc que bon on
passe comment on va pas se mentir
le jour avec les blancs est quand même
moins fort et moins bonne expérience que
duda donc je ne me positionne comme ça à
de résultats c'est quand même plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
mais seydou d'acquis qui a plutôt choisi
de bloquer prime
enfin il aurait pu jouer de manière
oui oui encore je vous ai chaque là
c'est vraiment le bloc 1 ils essaient de
bloquer et que éventuellement que prague
s'envoient en l'air mais sinon
il n'y a pas pas trop de risques quand
même pour pour le joueur blanc quoi
franchement il peut pousser a
tranquillement passé à deux doigts qu'il
prend pas trop de risques et c'est
vraiment des eaux plutôt serrure c1
contre la jeune star montante exactement
exactement il a peut-être peur aussi
d'une prépa de prague avec les blancs on
peut se dire ça et voilà est pas pas
trop à épiloguer là-dessus
bon ok moi je préfère quand la question
à se poser c'est est ce que je voudrais
parler est ce que maintenant après le
coup des noix est ce qu'on a le droit de
faire ou 5 ou non je dis que j'aimais
pas ce coup là mais avec le cahier un g4
qui ne peut plus revenir sur la case
naturel peut-être qu'on peut l'entrevoir
et cherchez pas des choses comme ça avec
avec du travail sur le cavalier qui
serait un peu coincé pourquoi pas
balancer tous les pions soyons fous la
joue comme stouff là c'est ça tu veux un
stéphane que tu veux tu veux que j'en
vois tous mes pions comme ça profitons
du centre bloqué chez pas c'est pas
impossible peut-être de jouer comme ça
la dre 5 c'est un coup de clic amassé
comité du vide à la casse des 5 ou de
les doter le cavalier fois plus en
gagnant en veut oui les longs mois c'est
pour ça que je me permets un sinon j'ai
pas le droit de passer expliqué si
lecavalier était f6 ce serait un coup à
deux points d'interrogation au 5 serait
très mauvais parce qu'on donne à cause
des saints qui on donne tout quoi mais
le cavalier en fait un peu de rangement
de 5 on joue vraiment sur la le cavalier
sur le cavalier g4 qui mal placé et
éventuellement un jour peut-être pouvoir
être des cinq puis on prendrait pour
prendre qui est une possibilité
complètement
propositions
plutôt cool
moi franchement je crois bien cette
position c'est intéressant je trouve que
la position de mon petit poulain elle
est prometteuse donc sa
position est ce que je vous propose
c'est maintenant d'aller voir
d'aller voir richard rapporte parce que
c'est ce que néandertal nous demandait
tout à l'heure et du coup on n'a pas vu
jordan brand forest et après en poids on
aura fait un tour complet me semble-t-il
en plus il ya déjà eu deux parties
nulles donc ça on a 500 clando s'ils
allaient voir avec grande des lieux et
après pouvoir retourner moi j'ai
vraiment hâte souffle à la partie qui
mue qui me plaît le plus c'est comme
hier c'est mamediarov
puisque la partie était totalement
fantasque on vous l'a montré tout à
l'heure donc allez on est parti voir
richard rapporte et
et donc du coup je vais vous mettre pop
la cam de richard laporte voilà avec
vent de forest on le voit richard
rapporte avec les pièces blanches et ses
cheveux longs du coup ok pour l'instant
on va voir comment on est arrivé là mon
écot 11e coup donc ça n'avance pas
beaucoup
ok on est dans un des bus lave cavalière
trois cavaliers m6 toujours slave
normalement un vent de forest c'est
plutôt des slaves semi cela peut arriver
aussi mais surtout slave et qui a validé
des deux
déjà un coup assez étonnant un coup un
petit peu sans théorie voilà on essaie
de jouer de jouer hors de la théorie sur
le cavalier c3 on pouvait s'attendre à
une vraie slave classique un cavalier c3
et on aurait assisté comme comme dans
beaucoup mais bon la semi on en a parlé
mais la vraie slave avec des français et
sur l'a4 au kef au f5 voilà la vraie
slave en fait qui ressemble un petit peu
aux candidats à accepter pour le moment
mais en fait en jouant à quatre les
blancs s'assure de la reprise du pion c4
seulement voilà ligne de base dans la
slave quand vous dit voilà c'est j'ai
joué une slave aujourd'hui normalement
c'est plutôt ce type de position
sur cavaliers c3
des fois on voit des fouets f5 aussi et
cavaliers h4 c'est un thème va regarder
avec cavaliers en d2 qui protège le pion
ses cadres donc pas forcément d'intérêt
de le prendre pour mettre deux cavaliers
sur une belle case là les noirs ont joué
faux f5 sur une belle diago est une des
idées ça peut être cavaliers h4
évidemment ici pour enlever le foot ça
bêle diago et si je le mets ici angers 4
je me prends un choix et surtout à
chaque jeu peut partir à la chasse aux
fous voilà et surtout j'ai si je peux le
prendre maintenant quand je veux avec
mon cavalier du bord c'est la raison
pour laquelle vent le forez qu'il devait
connaître cette position et je fous au
cices il a un petit peu bizarre en 6
mais c'est peut-être la case voulait le
moins pire parce qu'on sait huit mois
c'est retour à la maison en dix-sept il
va gêner mon cavalier b8 et en russie si
j'ai nokia e72 sortie du foyer fuite
mais je pourrais le sortir par là stouff
voilà voilà donc pointé pas palpitant
notamment et donc moi je sans toi
je t'aime ou simplement très longtemps
un canard ya un moment et
ce fou ce qu'on sait jamais si fantasque
il faut le sortir et à quel moment et où
es tu et là on voit qu'il posera des
problèmes c'est pas évident ouais bon
après vente forest il est vraiment
spécialiste est rompue en assurant je
pense qu'il va arrive quoi ça a l'air
d'être une partie assez plate donc g6 le
coût attendu b3 on vous avait annoncé
que et c'est vrai un richard rapporte
c'est un joueur fantasque et jordan il
est capable d'aller dans la grosse
baston a pour l'instant c'est tout calme
tout mou et le débat va commencer bien
après petit rock tour c1 pour l'instant
les coûts sont normaux des deux côtés
cavalier e cat enfin un petit peu
d'ambition dans cette partie avec l'idée
de changer la structure sur cavaliers
prend le 4 pions prend un cadre le
quadrillage 4 resterait très très mal il
y aurait même des menaces de jets
singles donc on ne peut pas vraiment le
cas ou alors on le prend mais on fait
j'ai trois cavaliers j'ai deux essais le
cavalier affirme qu eto ça existe pas
vraiment et en plus on risque les c5
puisque le fou est posté faso 2 si on
peut éviter ce genre de sketches et
mieux donc il a ramené le cavalier h4
qui était mal placé et maintenant que le
pion et angers si c'est pas si simple de
jouer au f5 1 parce qu'on n'a pas la
case de recul on peut se faire embêter
presque tout le temps donc il ya eu
damas cinq dames à 5 c'est un coup
piquant il se sert de saddam il attaque
à deux mais pression sur le cas des deux
à trois c'est normal
hélas oui c'est sympa ce qu'a fait ce
café vanves on ne vous reste que je suis
en train de regarder moi tranquille ou
cavaillé 17 maintenant il a fessé 5
le roi n'a pas encore roque et jenny
m'ont forgé cette face aux fauves et de
non protégés ils jouent ces cinq et ils
me le bordel au centre parce que le roi
est en eux un donc c'est extrêmement
logique et là il ya eu food et 3 de la
part des blancs et j'ai l'impression que
ça va être une partie assez plate parce
que je sens que ça va arriver je souffre
le cavalier prend des deux et les
changes estiment pétange et les pions
qui vont songer aux cendres ça risque de
nous amener ça va une position assez
plate ont massivement sa pâle est rigolo
ben du coup
j'ai envie de fuir et de ne pas proposer
à nos spectateurs cette partie mais
une partie un peu plus rigolotes est ce
qu'on va voir chant clan des grands des
lieux s'il semble que c'est la seule
partie se trouve qu'on n'est pas les
voir
aller on peut aller voir ça puis après
on ira voir car la scène en scène qui a
perdu le purin 4 je pense qu'il a donné
en fait mais donc on va aller voir cette
démarche et je pense ok eh ben ça marche
alors eh ben voilà la cam de deux grands
delius
alors comment on est arrivé ici une
anglaise
avec g3 donc du grand classique anglais
symétrique à envoyer les deux joueurs
jouent exactement pareil et un moment le
joueur noir a décidé de rompre la
symétrie en faisant à ce thème bobigny
qu'avec un vague les noirs qui
contrôlent des katas fonds est par
contre le bémol c'est que ça c'est très
bien de contrôler des cartes que ça
donne un trou et s'enferme un peu moins
g7 du coup le plan qui va arriver on le
connaît c'est le plan elle dame à trois
cavaliers j'ai eu 7 et à terme les
blancs joueront avec avec b4 donc
détroit un plan aussi qu'on voit très
régulièrement c'est ça et la case là il
ya deux plans qui nourrissent la tour b
1b 4 et le plan toc dhostel cavalli en
d5 sur l'avant poste si vous voulez ce
qui permet aussi de faire vivre le fou
g2 donc là on se régale c'est un petit
peu long tout ça mais où est la position
est ferme et on est très bien que ya pas
de pression au centre il ya pas de puits
ont échangé a pas de cologne ouverte à
dreux vraiment le temps de deux médecins
en pratique mettant en place parce que
il n'y a rien de
position ferme et position à manoeuvre
donc position les cars magne et bouge
beaucoup tout à fait
et là c'est vraiment intéressant pour
vous est ce que disent tous et il faut
que vous réussissiez à identifier les
positions fermes et des positions
ouvertes et attention aux faux amis les
positions fermes et où il ya une énorme
rupture possible et qui va tout [ __ ]
en l'air bas il faut s'en méfier
forcément
donc petit rock a suivi qui a validé
deux on comprend maintenant que cavani
va peut-être venir là donc d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs cavaliers 2 qui d'être plus
malin avant de faire petit rock parce
que c'est ce que tu as d'imagés plus à
caser f1 pendant cavalli qui pourraient
venir en trois axes varié où on fait
face petit rock tour ou un peu cavalier
f1 donc je prendrai un petit peu de
temps donc du goût des fois les blancs
vont retarder le rock pour faire
cavalier f1 cavaliers 3 bon après ça
c'est un plan et d'églises beaucoup de
plans possibles donc si jamais son plan
c'est de faire ça il est malin de temps
des drogues sont assez connus de cette
position est connue mais ni du grenelle
us a dû considérer que ça restait solide
et du coup sûr bekkat il va surtout pas
prendre b4 parce que sinon je ramène des
pions vers le centre et lui perdrait son
pion c5 on le pion à 3 au final après
cet échange donc il a consolidé avec b6
qui est le grand classique c'est la
raison pour laquelle il avait enlevé sa
tour 2 à 8 ans b 8 parce que sinon il y
aurait eu b5 dans cette position et on
perdait la partie donc cavalier f1
l'autre plan maintenant est mis en
action fourbe et sept cavaliers de trois
cavaliers des quatre pour échanger le
fou du fomc et aux défenseurs du roi
maintenant c'est quand même le fou qui
circule ce fou bessette d'ongles et
blanc accepté de faire la petite
concession du roi pour mettre en place à
terme le cavalier vraisemblement en d5
petit rock a été joué considérant que je
me fais pas maté f5 cavalli eu des cinq
je prends la case il m'en fous contrôle
des f4 potentiel la patrie ne pouvait
être une grosse menace pour la
session là les blancs sont beaucoup
mieux sur le long terme avec peut-être à
4 à 5
rupture la rupture et je pense que ça va
être rigolo comme partie parce que niels
gron des lieux vacants va essayer de
tenter quelque chose à l'ale
avec le trou qui l'a qu'il a créé je
pense qu'on va avoir une partie assez
déséquilibré est assez intéressante du
jeu positionnelle des blancs qui va
arriver vite mais les noirs pourraient
très bien tenté d des petits guily comme
cela est allé
essayer en tout cas de titiller le roi
2 500 clan de voilà ce que je propose
pour grand delius on a déjà vu cette
poussée du pion h récurrente à haut
niveau pour aller à faiblir encore plus
un petit rock et la procédure qui ont
acheté ce qui nous a fait oublier un peu
le moins souffert vraiment
je pense que c'est ça
mais je vois beaucoup moins de
possibilités dans la position noirs ici
j'ai vraiment moi j'aime vraiment les
blancs le sien d'accord cette pause
parce que bon on fait qu'ils avalent epr
en cavale et pense j'aime beaucoup
l'idée de jeu avec a4 a5 et jouer sur le
pion v6 est bon les noirs sur les ovales
chaque âge 4 c'est chaud mais c'est la
partie d'ailleurs parfois je suis un
joueur en plus moi je suis un joueur qui
aime bien attaquer tu vas donc j'aime
bien généralement
à voir des noirs dans les positions et
qui commence à faire h 5 h 4 tout ça
ouais mais j'ai dit voilà j'ai eu du mal
à croire à ces attaques du coup je
me fou n'est plus là bon
elle peut coulisser la rigolade sa tour
qui ne sert à rien elle dame est très
très vite en un coup elle peut s'activer
en 1 ou 2 go donc
- ch en fait j'adore le a4 a5 que tu
évoques mais je suis un peu trouillard
pour tout dire stouff
dans cette potion en fait aux échecs
pour tout avouer tout j'aime pas qu'on
m'attaque le roi j'aime bien
mais c'est un peu ça maintenant
maintenant comme je vieillis je
m'arrange pour qu'on m'attaque pas le
roi souffre j'arrive à perdre autrement
quand je perds même est parti mais
normal on touche tous avec des noms mais
ça m'arrive ça m'arrive quand même qu'on
réussisse un sou mais non non mais
j'aime pas j'aime pas qu'on attaque le
roi pourtant en plus on peut défendre
etc mais c'est psychologiquement
inconfortable si vous voulez je pense
pour beaucoup de joueurs d'échecs un peu
comme quand on est on est jeune en
particulier les tout jeunes joueurs
d'échecs préfère attaquer que se faire
attaquer et un haut niveau on voit
justement c'est un petit peu particulier
que les joueurs s'en fiche un petit peu
ils sont capables d'attaquer et
ii est de défendre et en fait on dit
même que des fois l'attaquant a pas mal
de choix alors que le défenseur il va
être obligé de jouer être précis sur
chaque coup de l'adversaire mais il a un
choix un choix plus restreint de coûts
et du coup c'est des fois plus facile de
défendre si tenté que la position elle a
à peu près à l'équilibré évidemment
entre des joueurs partis qui est
beaucoup plus prometteuse que jusque là
j'adorais la partie de ma médias off
après j'étais un peu resté sur ma faim
s'était pas encore partie là la partie
promet d'être sympa à mon sens souffle
c'est une des parties qui m'intéresse le
plus
ah il ya eu le très intéressant f4
d'ailleurs un c'était un coup vraiment
potentiel d'attac en boîte et grands
delius je pense qu'il est content parce
qu'on a vu hier sa partie
des plus simples il envoie quoi c'est un
joueur hyper bien les mecs c'est vrai
que ce fait la différence de style des
deux joueurs vin vieux c'est le genre
qui aime bien [ __ ] le bordel et bien
attaquer l'année les prises sont
compliquées alors que champion il aime
bien tout contrôle et
est du coup ben là on voit clairement
que champion n'est pas forcément dans sa
zone de confort après que quand deux et
réussi à trouver du jeu avec f4 donc
voir un peu comment ça serait étonnant
c'est bien sûr f4 je verrai bien ce que
je jouerai en petit joueur qui aime pas
se faire attaquer se trouve j'aurais
bien étroit
et du coup tu vois je laisse une sorte
de perspectives de match nul tu vas
grande classe g en fait j'aurais hyper
peur de prendre ce pion légèrement
poison et on peut peut-être d'y aller
mais ça va laisser des perspectives
aux
pièces adverse de se ramener donc je ne
prends pas et jouent le e3 pour dégager
la belle pièce de l'adversaire et
peut-être après revenir avec mes pièces
et échanger sur la côte est fait
proposait
pas un match nul mais un qu'on se calme
un petit peu con
et qu'on joue aux échecs un peu plus
tard avec moi à 4 à 5 fois ci tu vois là
j'aimerais bien faire le mode un peu
anti jeu par rapport à l' attaque
adverse et je vois bien ce 3 en plus qui
casse un peu l'activité du cac et des
cartes donc ça peut pas être mauvais à
mon avis ça va être ça va être sympa
et julien qui veut voir ta au tata steel
veut voir mvl et malheureusement tu le
verras pas julien s'est pas gérable
n'est pas la fille rousse ja non plus et
ils font quel tournoi et je crois qu'ils
font une tournoi à la maison le tournoi
le tournoi
le tournoi de s'entraîner tranquille à
la maison
ouais il ya rarement deux gros tournois
ensemble à tous c'est vraiment
extrêmement rare extrêmement rare un peu
comme comme au tennis un enfant et un
calendrier qui est cadré par la fidh
aucun intérêt de mettre de gros tournois
en place au même moment sauf quand il ya
des bibelots etc mais en règle générale
le tata steel c'est un des gros tournois
qui s'applique aux russes avant qui
existe depuis des lustres on va pas
concurrencer un tournoi comme celui-là
ok donc du coup partie intéressante mais
je vois bien le 3 raisonnable a pour
pour l'adversaire non ils ont pas le coc
vide s'est passé passant on a expliqué
rapidement que furent où déjà il y avait
un petit refait un petit gros truc avec
l'organisateur l'an dernier ils ont pas
réussi à s'arranger cette année pour
qu'ils participent et maxime je crois
qu'il n'a pas eu d'invitation je sais
pas trop comment ça se passe au niveau
des invitations pour ce tournoi là c'est
aussi à la pression de l'organisateur
qui invite évidemment le numéro un
mondial et
il ya aussi les hollandais parce que
c'est c1 c'est aux pays bas que ça se
déroule et caetera et caetera et après
on aime bien représenté dans de oued
tous les pays et je pense que en fait ce
qui a peut-être des séries jean sérien
mvl c'est qu'il voulait invité fil rouge
à fuir ou de gens n'est pas venu mais
bras c'est dommage il ya quelqu'un qui
dise ça dans le chat tiers qu'ils aient
assez dommage que la place de fil rogers
n'est pas proposée mvl voilà ça
s'arrêtait ça aurait été sympa de le
voir dans ce tournoi c'est certain alors
c'est quand est ce que tu sais quel
joueur quel est le joueur qui remplaçait
firooz non bonne question à se poser au
chat
bon
ouais bah alors on a un français quand
même hein on en français
julien bontemps moi c'est dans
l'automate challenger donc c'est marc
andré amoretti que je passe tu connais
le jeune jeu le jeune français corse qui
est devenu grand maître à 14 ans vers en
valais
en attendant la petite partie
avant d'aller voir peut-être mamediarov
et après on ira voir notre français qui
jouent dans le tournoi b mais ce n'est
pas passé grand chose du coup le central
est décisif où j'ai 3 et fourbe et 4,1
cou noir depuis que les parties
romantique ça sexy de moi
ça c'est assez logique alors du coup
quand ce n est donc qu un seul a fini
par donner ce pion à tokyo keiki était
que vouée à être mangés 1 on vous
rappelle ceux qui n'ont pas suivi le
départ il ya une catalane voilà avec la
grande rares cavaliers à trois et on
s'était arrêté avec un stouff sur le à
4,2 magnus qui visait x 3 et les cases
noires et du coup alors tu nous dis que
le pion à quatre volets c'est sarah
stuff donc fois trois tours 8 accords
logique une âme celle de pression sur le
puits ans et quatre
cavaliers b17
torah c'est un bon train pas cavalier b6
qu'on a toujours à 5 n'ont pas de
problème on y va
donc à six a été jouée d'un prend c4 et
la sueur qui avait b6 n'y a plus rien il
ya juste du contre eux je
vraisemblablement c'est à dire que on à
la paire de fou le centre potentiel
parce qu'on a deux pions contraint au
centre et on se débrouille avec ça pour
pour lutter avec le pion de moi on a des
compensations la niche geek qui joue un
peu la méthode de l'anti jeu avec 100
points de plus qui propose les changes
des dames quand je dis anti jeu c'est
juste pour vous faire comprendre que
normalement ce le camp qui a le plus de
matériel va et cd changer les pièces
ça semble ça semble logique pas donc du
coup ce qu'un par contre on prendre dans
cette position parce que là vous allez
me dire ok mais car c'est la difficulté
maintenant -
alors moi moi je vous avoue avec les
blancs qui répandent en sécurité parce
que ben
champions - et que j'ai pas niveau de
quinssaines de vraiment comprendre
toutes les subtilités et les contre les
cons et des
compensations dans la position
mais
ici on voit clairement qu'il ya la part
de fouras merci de faire des couleurs
passe moi je te fais des couleurs
toujours pour t'aider jamais
[Rires]
d'habitude ça me fait rire important
du coup non il répare des fous pour le
blanc clairement donc ça c'est et on a
aussi les colonnes baissé dans un but
commun bengo ainsi vous connaissez un
peu d'ouverture
aux grecs colonnes pour les tours de
créer une pression sur le fiancé ces
êtres sans prendre 17 est ce qu on
pourrait regarder la ici moi je pense
qu'il va garder les dames
c'est moi je pensais à jouer dans le c2
c'est ma première idée
certains pensent mais en fait ils
risquent âge devient il va te souviens
juste doit être le partage de connexion
condé quoi le partage d'écran et je
viens de voir les couleurs 10es jeux je
suis un petit peu comment dire sur les
fesses j'ai compris ni le premier ni
deuxième coulant vous proposer la
cds couvrant dit on va garder mes tongs
repas quand on n'a pas envie de regarder
ce que c'est vraiment trop dur je pense
[Musique]
et mais
le tour français si c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus normal pour
moi dans le sens où il sa force d'un
processus
comme si une vente forcée on peut
l'imaginer ça tu reprends ses six
cavaliers
5dans b5 et après dun bessac je pense
que j'aurais fait comme toi je trouve ce
ne sera arrêtée là en me disant j'ai pas
assez
et voilà j'aurai j'aurais refusé cette
variante ouais bon jeu club comme ça
clairement un coup aussi alors je pense
qu'on va on voit là c'est raté je gage
que là vraiment on va regarder la vente
ont brossé 6 pour expliquer un petit peu
au chat ce qui se passe vraiment
tactique on peut se dire on fait tourner
le radar taccoen et on regarde on
observe sur processus parce que c'est
une possibilité tactique en avant leurs
gardes à la vague mais on va envahir
sympa on va bouger un petit peu les
pièces surprend m'a dit si c'est
intéressant si on élimine deux
défenseurs du cavalier donc s'ils
mangent la tour eh ben ça avec le pion
simplement et ben je fais d'aprr en
cavale est censé recouvrir chose à voir
donc cette possibilité on va l'enlever
maintenant entre autres processus il a
d'un prend b3 où il a aussi dit en
français si ce regard des 2
donc sur dans le train des trois
engagements en bête
en b3 et maintenant quand tu vas manger
après en c6 et ben je mangerai en 1/4 et
j'aurai une quêté de moins mais là car
de fou et aussi plus tard depuis peu
nous montrer ses 12 et des pièces pour
le chat voilà donc deux qu'on n'a pas le
choix a dit on peut pas prendre en b3
dont le fait d'armes français 6 à 12 ans
je n'ai pas fini explique dame des pins
thématique sur celle là parce que vous
voyez d'un pro b 3 à prendre et 3 je
suis dit qu'on avait un chat hyper
éclairé que tout le monde voyait le
cavaliere à 4 en l'air c'est à dire sur
b prend bébé prend et du coup là on peut
pas en quoi je veux cette position
serait tu manges là et l'atteignent
qualité de moi enfin tata deux pièces
pour la tour attaque avait le 5 qui
arrive tu as le pion c'est ce qui va
tomber et la tare de fouet trop fort ça
ça va être un gros avantage pour le
lance m à 1,5 donc on va revenir en
arrière et du cou
on va voir que d'un process six et du
coup obligatoire sur trop processus et
garçonne je pense qu'il peut faire parce
que contre les politiciens ils avaient 7
numéraire calculé je pense qu'ils
aillent philippe
lorteau qu'on saisisse tour précédent
prend donc on est obligé de réguler où
on servait la défense cavaliers au salon
on va essayer d'enlever la dame de la
défense du cavalier dans le bessin
seulles case pour défendre le cavalier
là en fait c'est là que c'est dur pour
beaucoup de joueurs de loin parce que
l'on bouge les pièces donc on a triché
on peut dire là il faut un tamm c2 qui a
un coût on peut pas échanger dans si on
peut ça existe des fois mais avant nous
vient de s'acheter une qualité on avait
aussi un pion de moins hélas là il ya
peut-être du jeu ce que les pièces
noires sont un peu bizarre
j'ai une pression énorme
pression la menace pour bella
la dame elle est à la shoah
ça devrait gagner en ligne je pense
cette position ce que damas est donc sur
pirelli béziers
sur camel et b6 si tu peux le jouer ce
pasqua a maintenant je peux me bouffe
est là et à ça et ça état au pire des
cas du processus et tu récupères nato
donc ton matériel il est récupéré et tu
as une bonne position as tu as tu gardes
ton centres mobiles d'intel qui ont des
quatre jours durant 4 jours 3 ou même
défaut 4 tu as le choix un peu de tout
ça moi je pense que s'il arrive hélas
très facilement c'est à dire après dame
ces deux et ils essayent de trouver
comment le joueur noir peut s'en sortir
et en fait ça a l'air extrêmement dur de
s'en sortir dans cette position et je
regarde
le plafond de 12 ha et tout cela
par une ligne peut-être qu'il a réussi
et ce serait tout à fait possible de
voir qu'à et b6 vous prend bessette a
cavalé c4
avec le fourbe et 7 en l'air
parce que nous on avait les pièces c'est
plus facile mais surtout celle ci ses
cavaliers à 3
donc tu prends à 8 qui avait des points
à 3 et dames c6 peut-être
vous voyez là la cdu même pour magnus
parce que nous on bouge les pièces et du
coup vous voyez en plus c'est le bordel
de sa cible iliad imposerait mais on va
faire des erreurs de calcul il ya
peut-être dames seniors
mais leur bus ont bougé les pièces
pendant ma voix
mais en fait il est obligé alors on voit
que à nice guy ilary là
[Musique]
il à plancher bas ça y est c'est jouer
ça vient d'être jouée par magnus il a
mangé ses six boom quel génie and you it
en fait je pense que glee je pense pas
qu'il va être trop surpris par ce coup
là parce qu'il l'a calculé ses obligés
qu'ils les calculs et
donc ils avaient sans doute calculé tour
français six dames français et six
cavaliers 5 et d'un bep 5 il a forcément
regarder un petit peu s'il n'y avait pas
un problème toute façon il est obligé
donc il va reprendre ses six assez
rapidement au moins comme ça un coup
force et il va le jouer rapidement pour
dire j'avais vu t'inquiète pas d'un
procès si ce n'est obligé il n'y a pas
d'intérêt de réfléchir trop longtemps
puisque a pas d'alternative voilà il a
déjà joué
ok donc ça on comprend magnus il a joué
cavalier seul
clic sur le milieu là non entre les noms
en bas à la fraîche en découlent oui moi
je lance ici la lutte au dessus le
peuple juste au dessus oui
et là ça revient au même ça tape il tape
eu des coups ça va revenir
automatiquement et ça va parce que la
joie qui fait à la main à la mano mais
en fait vous savez ça m'a remis en
arrière souffle merci oui mais depuis
que sur des coups mais non mais c'est
bon ah ouais elle et ça marche parce que
je faisais à la mano
alors stop me surveille techniquement un
vous voyez il n'y a pas confiance en moi
que je surveillais bien un petit truc à
la mano mai on sait pas dérangeant de
voir tes flèche c'est ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas dérangeant et magnus à trouver
dams et de on vous en parlait c'est le
coup clé et je pense qu'il a trouvé vite
et là je suis persuadé qu'à nice grivaz
va mettre en place une petite réflexion
parce que ce n'est pas facile de jouer
cette position la menace tour bien et
est tellement forte est ce qu'il aurait
oublié dames c'est 2
à votre avis n'hésitez pas à nous le
dire dans le chat parce que qu'est-ce
qui va nous raconter là c'est assez
intéressant de regarder la came pour
voir un peu la tête d'un algérie
un peu des joueurs voir ce qu'il ce
qu'ils pensent qu'ils ont calculé sont
sur pied ce qu'ils sont à l'aise pas à
l'aise et ben franchement il ya un gros
pressing
gros pressing ça sent pas très bon pour
anis guéri mais je pense qu'il avait il
avait prévu mais c'est des monstres
parce que s'ils avaient tout prévu avec
basse et c'est vraiment pas impossible
parce qu'il avait pris une très grosse
réflexion ses fans donc je pense que
c'est vraiment probable qu'il est
qu'il ait pensé à cavaillé bessy saur
qu'est ce qui nous fait line nault et
regarder le plafond quand les amis à
regarder le plafond et les joueurs alors
si vous voulez progresser aux échecs
essayez de regarder le plafond mais vous
avez vous bien vous apercevoir la rive
gauche aux élections de la faune c'est
juste que eux ils ont véritablement
l'échiquier dans la tête kasparov aussi
à son époque faisait cela est du coup il
pense encore du coup ça va être des
temps un petit peu ne pas regarder
l'échiquier puis ils sont contents de
faire ça je sais pas le faire non plus
hein c'est juste qu'ils sont au dessus
et
du coup ils sont faciles même s'il a la
position d'anigo guéri et franchement
c'est super sympa parce que cette partie
on sait maintenant qu'elle va être assez
spectaculaire
on est très clairement elle est déjà
jolie en fait cette partie et cavaliers
à trois avec jeu avec ce qu'on voit de
la partie de manu cela ça c'est certain
que ce sera réétudié je sais que j'avais
fait un petit fichier à l'époque sur ce
souk ou dans la catalane et du coup j'ai
regardé après soir ce que j'avais dans
mes assurément on pourra les emplois à
les voir elle sera peut-être rejouer
leurs prix mais il est clair que magnus
a ici une position ambitieuse et c'est
difficile pour un et figari de jouer
contre tours b un loup noir hier c'est
vraisemblablement de faire cavalier b6
et dcb set mais c'est un gros calculs et
il est obligé de tout vérifier il a la
grosse pression on a dit hamilton
davantage de caractère dans cette
position c'est qu'en fait
mais il voit qu'il a trouvée dans ces
deux c'est maintenant avec dire il
trouvait le coup de défense et
du coup bon tu vois qu avait laissé
quatre cépages bon cru a trouvé à leur
niveau ça va être facile mais du coup
c'est en fait il va mais après faut le
juger et comme c'est le bazar total il
ya quand même
il ya quand même un sacré boulot
l'allemand
c'est enfin y'a pas qu'après après tout
c'est son sens le pion cessera fèves on
avait 10 ans et 7
mètres pour enfants et un poil rejouer à
ces quatre et ça envoie
donc du coup donc du coup quand même
position qui fait voir aux créanciers
royal prend à trois ça c'est ce qu'ils
vont jouer vraisemblablement dames 16 6
c'est fort probable aussi pour avoir le
pressing donc d'un point de
ces hyper chaud il faut baisser de
quelque chose comme ça vraisemblablement
alors les pions sont fun moi je peux
encore perdre celui-là mais le cavalier
est bizarre aussi ici donc ça promet
cette partie
bon il ya sûrement un plus pour qu'un
scène mais c'est peut-être qu'à que
visuel on va voir voir c'est hyper
intéressant en tout cas ce qu'est ce
qu'il a fait c'est hyper ambitieux et je
pense qu'à nice guy il est en train de
vérifier mais par défaut il est
quasiment obligé stéphane de jouer cela
ce serait étonnant enfin on va pas jouer
des passifs tourbe et 8 ou des choses
comme ça parce qu'il ya tour b1 et sur
damas cinq fauves et 4 ça sent vraiment
mauvais on est limite à se faire
enfermer la dame et si on ne s'est pas
enfermé la dame ah oui peut-être entre
torah et ou re la différence
j'avais pas vu surtout eb 8 comme ça ça
protège bessette on peut ramener la dame
en 1/8 et tenir cavaliers ses fans je
n'ai pas pensé à ceux
là
donc c'est vraiment qu'on joue à tour b
donc il est tombé vite tour bien après
g/km v7 il faut qu'on décèle faut
prendre ça ne s'est pas mieux je cavale
et 6 mois donc en fait c'est sûr
maintenant c'est
on pourrait faire un petit prono et je
vois bien le coude à nice guy cavaliers
b61 honnêtement je vois pas ce qui va
jouer d'autres et je le verrais bien
joué assez vite c'est à dire que je
pense qu'il dépassera pas 35 minutes
voilà mon petit prono se trouve
maintenant je m'amuse à faire des pronos
sur la rapidité des coûts et on vous
rappelle qu'il ya un seul enjeu
aujourd'hui ainsi
si prague nalanda bayane christophe duda
je dois sabah stuff et ça me ferait mal
parce que je n'ai pas l'habitude ça ça
me ferait plaisir pour se trouve quand
même faut pas exagérer montes tu as
tellement offert des soldes toof qu'il
faut bien un manque qu'il se refasse
mais j'aimerais bien un petit contre de
jordan vente forez parce que dans la
règle c'est ouf qui m'offre un snob si
richard rapporte via un s'incliner
aujourd'hui on rappelle un hier c'était
déjà assez généreux de la part de ce
trouve puisqu'il m'a offert un beau
sobre pour la victoire devant le reste
sur grande des lieux alors qu'un moment
c'était très très chaud à manches qui ré
un peu la tronche puisque von euw
forrest avait perdu son avantage mais il
a réussi à se refaire dans le dialecte
dans le zag note du cou où on vous
envoie est ce que j'ai le droit d'aller
voir un peu la partie qui me faisait
sourire la partie de ma médias rohff
allez vas-y vas-y que lavelanet un petit
peu et c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir
on quand tu vois la position sans
calculer un on dirait un bullet de ce
touche au web avec les blancs bien sûr
souffle et ben ça va faire plaisir à
tous vos aussi alors il se retrouve chez
lui
et j'ai pas trop en faire mammadyarov et
ce que je l'avais trouvé oui je crois
annoncé c'est la cam 1 je crois parce
que je ne trouvais pas donc
je crois pas avoir là un point il faut
bien qu'il manque des joueurs
donc la non non c'est non non c'est fini
et n'ont pas changé nous ne devient en
technique au top et du coup tout à
l'heure ce qu'on a eu comme cam c'était
c'était celle là même le mix et on a eu
la chance de trouver et si penco bon
allez on sait nos petits délires
voiliers mais on arrive dans le bazar
total dans le bazar total et ses
excellents ce qu'a fait si bien qu on
vous rappelle ont été dans cette
position après h4
on vient pas sur comment on arrive et
cela on l'a déjà dit enfin si on revient
quand même on revient début classique
des cas de ces quatre cavaliers fils
aussi comme tout le monde est sûre dans
cette position mammadyarov a joué un
coup prépa maison et c'est hyper rare
d'en avoir au troisième coup j'ai 4 on a
eu la réponse dans le chatt 15e coût
théorique dans cette position donc la
même équipe et qu il ya de grandes
chances qu'on ne connaissait rien du
tout à la position il a donc joué le
dessin qu'il n'est pas rentré dans la
position d' acceptation du gambit mais
il a réagi au centre comme il faut le
faire quand vous faites attaquer à l
réaction centrale c'est le grand
classique au kef où j'ai deux fous
bekkat échec ok il réagit avec vigueur
et roy et fin de ma vie alors qu'il n'y
a pas trop le choix sinon ils perdent et
g5 dans de mauvaises conditions là le
pion g5 était toujours en prise mais n'a
pas voulu y aller parce que cavalier
angers 5 aurait été très moche du coup
il a joué fuglseth pourquoi se faire
enfermer le fou bekkat il ya des risques
de ces 5 à 3 b 4 avec le fou qui
clignotait rouge du coup sûr fouet cette
on défend à cache cache et voilà dans
quelle position n'était et ce qui est
marrant c'est que là ils ont peur de
rien et les joueurs et si bien qu il
voit les deux pions la casse qui fait
irak parce qu'il faut bien mettre son
roi à l'abri ne pas avoir peur de la
poussée de pions parce qu'elle n'est pas
accompagnée de pièces et ça permettra
surtout ici penco de réagir au centre
très prochainement puisque une attaque à
l voilà globalement ce qui s'est dit je
pense tous à peu près voilà exactement
mais c'est quelque chose comme ça
développement ici de m'hamed avec
cavaliers h3 bien sûr violent aussi
bizarre mais bon on joue un petit peu
trop sur les côtés et puis moi ça m'a
l'air vraiment quand même
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu trop
un peu too much
ses fantasmes et manuela filiale
habitudes
de nous faire revenir les potentats donc
le couple est qu'il est à l'aise a connu
sur un peu chelou mais ouais et puis il
avait des idées assez rapide
dans les ouvertures en fait souvent les
nouveautés à haut niveau et les
appareils 10 15e 20e 25e à partir du
deuxième coup là au troisième coup ce
n'est pas une nouveauté totalement mais
c'est un système jamais joué à un haut
niveau
et du coup c'est ça qui est assez
impressionnant avec mamediarov je
l'avais vu faire un tournoi aussi où il
s'était amusé à jouer
un truc que je ne connaissais pas du
tout c'est à dire une partie du centre
différé il commençait par un début
viennois et ensuite ils jouaient des
quatre ce qui n'existait pas je prends
juste un instant il m'avait étonné et
jouer un truc stouff je n'avais jamais
vu donc c'était j'ai vraiment analyser
je crois que tu peux pas j'ai pas moi de
jouer un autre premier confirmant que tu
cliques en rendent tout en bas soir
loupe peut-être que tu peux analyser la
à côté à gauche ouais je sais pas si tu
peux avoir un échiquier
la porte à j'espère que vous voyez bien
tout cela vérifier quand même moins on
peut analyser ouest et c'est juste ça tu
vois cavaliers ces trois cavaliers m6 et
maintenant des quatre
du délire encore prise des cas d'un
prend des quatre cavaliers c6
normalement quand joue système c'est
toujours pour aller 1-3 et lui allaient
en d3 avec vide et je sais pas si tu
connais ce système là mais c'était
vraiment sympa il avait joué un tournoi
à thème un tournoi rapide si vous voulez
et il s'amusait à jouer à jouer cela
j'étais hyper étonné quoi il se fait
plaisir le gadin médias rohff là encore
avec le blocus du foie f1 son idée est
ringard offs et sortir se fout là pour
faire grand qui perd rapide ils
s'amusent dans les ouvertures voilà donc
après bon c'est ça c'est assez compliqué
mais on voit qu'il a vraiment des idées
originales et cela rapidement dans les
ouvertures et qu'il a peur de rien il
n'est pas à jouer pour la position à
deux résultats il a envie de s'amuser
aux échecs et je dois avouer que j'aime
bien allez on revient sur sur nos partis
sur la partie est du coup toc et du coup
il ya eu des choses vraiment rigolote
puisque sur cave alliage 3u su à quoi
joue le coup sans saveur ses 6000 y
avait une grosse idée il renforce son
centre est sûre dame c2 ou d'un média
rohff a mis la pression sur le cavalier
e 4
et si bien qu il a joué un coup assez
classique eu cinq ans pour moi je dis
assez classique c'est-à-dire qu'il a
décidé de réagir au centre parce que le
roi est en f1 que lui son roi il estime
qu'il est tranquille du coup ils ouvrent
le centre et on est parti pour une
partie
hyper chaude et coup vite je vous dis
que ma il est mal autant ici penco oui
parce qu'il a été surpris rapidement
dans l'ouverture et que la position
extrêmement compliqué
alors on peut gagner un pion à la place
peut-être avec des choses comme ça moi
je n'ai pas trop envie de donner mon fou
g2 vous comprenez pourquoi pascal moreau
f1 j'ai pas envie de donner
mon fou quoi ça ça me dit pas du tout
donc je ne sais pas un coût qui me
paraît normal ces cavaliers c3 voilà
cavaliers ces trois soirées étaient
assez logique est la même il y aura un
jeu qui a aidé de un peu dans le même
style stouff voilà il essaie d'enlever
ce cavalier e cat donc qui est cavalier
prend des de fou prend des deux et puis
on prend des cats
ok ben lamb de la roche derrien un coup
comme steprans des 5 il va doubler puis
il y aura une position à double option
isolé au centre qui peut fermer certains
des cinq oui je t'en prie elles sont
censées prouver sa haine des blancs s'il
est noir foncé prendrait 5 mg à idron
deux pions doublé isolé des cinq des
caves donc on va pouvoir un peu paraître
cavaliers f4 penser à ta question des
cinq tons d un aussi bon les pions vont
être en difficulté et si sur ces points
des cinq noir foncé 5 pour garder le
pion en d4 c'est aussi un plan des
saintes donc et d'ailleurs je ferais
mieux d'aller comme e3 pour essayer
d'enlever ses options en dessin donc du
coup c'est tout casser et faire parler
la carte de fou et le passé en d5 donc
du coup non un médian pas une position
correcte impression assez bizarre très
marginal qu'il dira ok il a je l'aï la
jauge est 5 h quatre îles à
illac availlan h3 donc c'est assez
bizarre mais il ya des idées c'est
intéressant et on voit que xp mikko a
beaucoup de temps de retard il reste 24
minutes pour la fin de la partie bon
pour arriver au 40e coup je vous
rappelle la cadence
de la cadence c'était on avait dit une +
30 secondes par coup
1h40 pour dans une rue daran coûts déjà
way en s'appliquant à 50 minutes pour
voir l'un pour vaincre ou et un quart
d'heure pour le reste de la partie avec
à chaque fois une 30 secondes par coup
voilà l'un crémant de 30 secondes donc à
chaque fois que vous jouez un coût 30
secondes vous sont rajoutés ok
donc du coup
c'est très très bien
tac
donc donc ok position assez ses
standards
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait aller voir
maintenant
ok alors bas je te laisse me proposer
quelque chose dont on avait dit qu'on
irait voir notre petite pépite française
allez je pense que ça va m'attendre et
la voilà marquis joueurs comme on vous
dit à chaque fois encore je suis une
petite chose juste une petite chose je
vois une vache qui rit a fait une gaffe
aille donc il n'a pas trouvé on va aller
voir parce que avant d'aller parce qu'on
a quand même passé pas mal de temps à
regarder cela vole
c'est ça gouvy chc savez les meilleurs
et 30 secondes par coup donc tu peux
mettre moins moitié de temps comme une
fin
alors il a trouvé un peut-être farouk
seniors - synchro qu'on n'avait pas
envisagé qui a aidé 5 bon
ça a pas l'air en choisissez une guerre
j'ai vu un ordinateur les gars
c'est pareil je pense pas que tu lui
nous l'idée qu'on avait c'était de faire
tomber un et fourbe et 4 donc en fait
tourbains et la dame à 5 comme convenu
on a plus fourbe et 4 passes qu'il a mis
son cadet en d5
donc c'est pas évident de savoir
ici
que c'est un mauvais coup c'est un coût
humain tout à fait acceptable
et du coup maintenant j'ai enlevé tout
fait
ce qu'on voyait on a vu la variante du
coup est toujours frustrant on a du coup
on a eu là la raison même on va avoir du
mal à prouver je pense son ordi ça va
être assez rigolo on va s'amuser quand
t'as pas vu j'ai vu du coup on s'est pas
vu moi je la fais nous tentons bretonne
d'écran des fois je regarde aussi les
balles d'un coup il a bien raison
d'aidés mais ce n'est pas bien raison tu
as bien raison
donc ton bien d'un à cinq kbc 4
tu vois
donc donc damas cinq
l'intention qui avaient été 4 il va y
avoir dans ces trois des tours b 3
les jouets sexistes pourrait repartir et
aussi des standards il ya depuis cet
entrisme mais franchement c'est très
très difficile de trouver la bonne suite
à je crois qu'on a oublié la petite
pause qui est bénin à la petite pause il
a fait refaire la pause à ce moment là
où vous l'avez fléchir on va vous
laisser réfléchir dans cette position
les blancs jouer troubles avantage et je
trouve alors moi j'ai voulu coup sûr
l'ordinateur donc j'ai enlevé
l'ordinateur comme ça je le vois plus ce
que c'est toujours tentant quand on voit
la variation la barre de regarder et du
coup là il ya vraiment
un coup plus fort que les autres mais
même en connaissance de cause je trouve
que c'est un coût qui n'est pas évident
à jouer
donc voilà maintenant vous le savez on
va regarder on va regarder ça et si
magnus a bien trouvé tour b 1 il va bien
y avoir dame à 5 de son adversaire donc
vous déjà vous mettre cette position est
là on va faire notre petite pause
traditionnelle
alors moi je te propose que pour cette
pub là on laisse cet écran avec la
position pour qu'ils puissent voir un
peu afin que plus calculée par rapport à
l'exercice que tu as de leur donner un
exemple qu'en fait ce que tu as à faire
notamment inquiète t'inquiète je reste
qu'un terrain j'ai joué une coupe le son
on va on va régaler on va régaler on va
on va bien se retrouver donc on vous
laisse on va se retrouver d'ici quelques
secondes et je vais couper tout ça pour
que vous puissiez apprécier la partie
entre magnus carlsen est à nice guy à un
moment hyper intéressant allez on vous
dira tout de suite là tout de suite
et on est reparti pour la partie entre
magnus et
anish giri savas tous font jour en
commun on est là et ça commence à
devenir vraiment chaud
yes alors demain puisque le chat nous a
écrit ou alors à base d'oeuf ou c5 sous
b4g une réflexion en a qui voulait
piquer la dame on s'en fout c'est un fou
des deux mais c'était trop long par
exemple sur sur fou siège m'étais dit je
pourrais
b5 je m'étais dit ça marche parce que je
peux bien partir en b 6 il ya dame c3
qui était un coup à miel qui cavaliers à
4 quand même qui traînait
donc moi sur phocéen je voulais jouer b5
à la place de la place d'aniche mais
alors on va voir que tu vas me dire ce
qui a été proposé
donc on la cavale et c5
il veut jouer 4 qui est le cas très
intéressant était opposé
aux baies 5 non à tomber cette part
l'entraîneur
wissant ou normal mais bon je vous
rappelle qu'on a quand même
du matériel de moins donc là j'ai
vraiment à ça qu'on voudrait faire un
peu plus
est ce que quelqu'un a proposé là l'idée
souffre décisives ou non non j'ai pas eu
coup il a joué feront cavalier ces fonds
prend cammas est vraiment hyper
intéressant parce que honnêtement
c'est vraiment voilà un coût humain
hyper fort et je trouve que c'est c'est
assez logique je pense que l'idée c'est
de balancer d'un 9,5 dans la foulée pour
aller chercher le
le roi noir en tout cas c'est c'est
comme ça que le domaine et c'est hyper
embêtant de défendre de défendre et vii
je pense que c'est beaucoup le cavalier
vii et lettres qui périt dans 17 mois ça
peut être chaud
la première
mais il y avait aussi donc pour tout
vous dire donc ce que ce que l'ordi nous
proposer parce qu'on a vu le coût
malheureusement ça qu'on l'a enlevé 1 il
proposait fouet 4 qui est un coup de
folie
foucque être très dur est trouvé entre
le go ok un truc facile c'est que achi
c'est évidemment pas jouable je pense
que tout le monde peut le trouver ça
c'est que là il ya maintenant de qufu
achète rouages suite et cavaliers pro f
7 mais c'est peut-être deux intéresse
alors je le montre pour tout le monde de
foisches est attaque le roi ok j'ai
qu'une case est ok cavaliers premier set
mais sa voix trop pour les fuites oui
oui bien sûr 3 il est il et il est là et
contre la fuite ça c'était raisonnable
mais fou aux quatre
déjà on peut se dire premiers éléments
quand vous attaquez la contre-attaqué f5
et en fait là maintenant on peut faire
le coup de magnus en mieux encore
s'améliorer elle sera fait après la
course aux points f5 ce qui accroît des
cinq pardon ce qui est important c'est
que d'un point et a interdit à cause de
d'intrants cavaliers à 4/4 dans une
pièce et du coup sûr prenez 5 le seul
coup c'est eux prend des 5 et dans ce
cas là bas j'ai dame point f 5 gagnants
donc c'est la même chose que je voulais
faire sauter emplacement en mieux et à
la place des f 5 6 juger si c'était un
peu la même chose je pense prendre un
nom l'agipi d'anvers trek
oui c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas voulu
éditer vos l'idée ici est bien je ne
sais pas parce que là on ne l'avait pas
montré
un
[Musique]
quai c'est déjà plus dur de faire la
différence
on peut avoir envie de tout plaquer mois
risquent de manquer de matériel et 7 au
premier set il faut compter 5 puis on
prend on prend décès d'un de ses six
années la dame sera prêt une fois que
vous prend un pion protour promesses
elle est à lyon cette emprise sur des
champions c'est certes il peut faire
damas et six dans life si ceux ci
c'est assez difficile parce que même
regardé après faut prendre comprend 17
comment tu défends cette zone recèle il
faut qu'on le sait mais c'est très dur 8
c'est très dur en fait c'est un plus il
ya ça et il ya des problèmes
qui sont majorées à terme sur les cases
noires du coup la position était
extrêmement difficile
c'était vraiment trop dur n'a plus
jamais f6 pour virer le cavalier puisque
y aura même des claques angers 6 donc ça
faisait sans doute beaucoup dans cette
position bon ça passe de leur prouver
oui pardon
alors sur tourbe et s'attaque à vélib et
six dans le château nous dit alors je
pense que d'avoir d'un procès c est un
coup reach sur cavale et b6 parce que du
coup je me lasse dame prend f7 aussi je
me lasse le cavalier imbéciles sera
cloué montfoulon temps prison 23 certes
mais je te mangerais peut-être g7
malheur a perdu 1
on a dit donc la vouliez voir cavaliers
b6
a proposé quasthoff pardon dans cette
position d'homme c'est cette rencontre
cette fois là c'est cette règle et deux
pièces sur la septième rangée et là
c'est terminé
le cas et b6 est en l'air surtout réfute
gfu prend si j'ai besoin et le damiens
et qu'un échec de consolation puisque
gérois g2 du donc zéro problème dans
cette position alors maintenue s'il n'a
pas vu cette fille de là mais alors il
ya un truc c'est que avec souffre on a
été sympa avec vous on vous a dit il ya
un gain et magnus personne n'est venu
lui le dire et du coup si on lui avait
dit qu'il y avait un gain clair
peut-être je ne sais pas qu'il aurait
joué faux au cas où il aurait plus
chercher alors que là on voit qu'il a
beaucoup de temps la pendule et
continuer à mettre la pression
avec un coût tout à fait raisonnable
vous prendrez 5 ou dame prend 1 4 et 1
dames fondée 5 est interdite on a déjà
dit maintenant plusieurs fois à cause
d'un point à 4
on peut imaginer qu'il va jouer je
prends des cinq années je dirais puisque
je vois pas trop ce qui peut jouer
d'autres le et maintenant est ce que je
fais tout reprend bessette où est ce que
je fais parce que tout reprend mais
c'était très intéressant si si
est ce que j'ai en fait j'ai des f-5
comme coup candidats au tour prend
b757 tu j'ai l'impression
d'accord
du coup 2005 c'était aussi le coup je
voulais jouer et f6
ok si j'avais pas vu il ya eu un petit
trou dans la raquette et pour un parent
aussi tout à l'heure je te proposer des
f 5 mais après je sui bat f 6 en fait je
fais quoi alors que tout reprend
bessette maintenant que l'on a
éliminé
[Musique]
le cavalier basse a fait ça fait des
grosses menaces dette au premier set
avec menace d'un f 5 et 6 et qui sont
ces 7 par exemple qu'il faut vérifier
oui en plus d'amasser trois jeunes
n'avaient pas à cause de dame prend 1,4
ce qu'il faudrait maintenant je puisse
faire de l'anti jeu pour ce que là il ya
une qualité de moins mais le dynamisme
blanc est fou il ya une attaque sur le
roi qui se prépare matour a eu une
mauvaise pièce damas cinq pas terrible
cavalia 4 hyper mal au bord et qui rend
esclave la dame à 5 donc extrêmement
difficile ici de jouer cette position il
ya que la tour 8 qui est potable mais
c'est pas assez
voilà non mais là c'est la galère
donc je pense caniguy il est déjà
il est déjà extrêmement mal
mais on le pressentait un que c'était
pas facile cette position
je rappelle que la position qu'il avait
un jouet ou de lagaf et c'est là avec
cavaliers des 5
mais il fallait trouver un truc un petit
peu équilibristes en dans cette position
qu'on avait qu'on avait analysé donc je
sais pas c'est pas étonnant
qu'ils les gaffes et ici en fait on
avait dit qu'il fallait trouver le coup
de folie cavaliers b6 et surtout premier
set
il fallait trouver cavaliers s'écarter
on pensait qu'ils allaient le trouver un
peu par défaut
cc by en fait ce qui se passe c'est
caniguy voulait pas être mal autant du
coup il a joué qui a aidé 5 relativement
vite quand même et maintenant après tour
b1 et la suite relativement logique
parce que magnus il n'a pas joué le plus
précis font eux quatre mais il a quand
même trouvé un très bon coût humain et
il va du coup il s'est déjà plus quoi
jouer puis se retrouve quand même mal
autant et il a aggravé son cas voilà ok
c'est peut-être le moment pour nous
d'aller voir notre représentant
tricolore dans le tournoi b aller le
plus jeunes grands maîtres de
bah l'histoire de france
et du coup on parle bien de marc-andré
mao rizzi originaire de corse
voilà qui fait plaisir à toute la france
et à toute sa région et je vous ai
ramené comme un génie sur le tournoi
donc je vais dans le tournoi b
du coup on avait été regardé la partie
contre entre le cab en forêt ganguly ils
ont fait nul
le bourreau de marc andré a fait nul
avec des noirs et là beaucoup avancé
quand même la position de marc andry et
on est toujours avec le petit plus blanc
nous on était à peu près là tout à
l'heure donc avec cavaliers 3 donc
c'était l'ouverture du grand midam avec
une variante un peu marginal un côté
marc andry ça lui a permis de mettre le
cavaliere 5 et sur kg 6 une amie sont
fous en g3 on avait dit avec stouff qui
avait même des idées de
f4e bah finalement il en a rien été
puisque ya eu foule b4 hockey d'un b 3
gratuits coups de pied coups de poing
logique dames 7
et petit rock
ok c'est très très bien pour l'instant
est très naturel il se passait pas grand
chose jusqu'à leur faut aussi ce il a
remis sa dame en c2 et
la position est toujours plus agréable
avec les blancs un petit pressing stouff
avec des pièces
mieux placé
est du coup en face qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ben je me bats joumaa bat f rinat
de son prénom c'est plus simple donc les
kazakhes il est assez connu on le voit
maintenant autour de 26 50
du coût wes qui sait
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il a tenté
quelque chose je pense qu'il n'aimait
pas trop sa position où il subissait et
il attendait ses 5 ces cinq à l'idée des
français foot français et je m'active
mais en même temps je laisse un gros
pions gros pions isolé ça affaiblit
aussi le cavalier e52 marque andry mais
maintenant est ce que on pourrait pas
profiter de la masterclass dessous fier
sur pied isoler avec peut-être des idées
comme ça c'était hier ou aujourd'hui
c'était peut-être aujourd'hui en fait
qui nous a parlé de cela c'était
aujourd'hui en fait qu'elles font les
jours en fait je peux être qu'on a
oublié englober on va pouvoir bloquer le
le pion isolé
alors bien évidemment il ya plus de
l'handicap les noirs 20 12 d4
donc si on peut garder le pion de cinq
ans vie
c'est plutôt une bonne une bonne idée
donc avalé f3 ici paraît logique en way
et du coup donc ça paraît logique mais
j'ai envie de jouer
cavalier b5 ici
ouais si c'est possible parce qu'on va
devoir vérifier un petit peu
j'aimerais bien avoir plus mais
peut-être qu'à tours à ses 8 parce qu en
fait une des idées dans cette position
qui a et b 5 je joue pour le bloqueur un
peu comme ma cavalière 3g pas dans quel
sens sur le jouer mais caraïbes et cinq
gymnases cavalli c'est cette dent dans
ce genre d'histoire up non mais je crois
que ça va pas à cause de k&b 5 3 6 et 8
je voulais vous voyez un maître
lecavalier en d4 mais là je vais me
faire peut-être un petit peu un petit
peu secoué donc peut-être que cavalier
alors il est raisonnable
moi je le faire cavaler f3 tout
simplement parce que
ben il ya un vis-à-vis cld âme
peut avoir un fou des 600 cavaliers h5
schéma
je
préfère m'enlever mes pièces et jouer
clairement pour le case alors qu'avec
des bassins qui s'avère un peu plus
freestyle ouais en fait non mais assez 8
et c'est quand même un petit peu
énervant de se prendre la cavalière 3
c'est simple soit cavaliers b5 c'est
très bon dans ce cas on le joue pour
avoir encore plus soit on se contente de
cavaliers f3 avec l'idée du bloqueur
notre cahier b5 qui a aidé 4 arrivera
après mais pour l'instant cavalier f3
est très raisonnable dans l'idée
d'empêcher des quatre se fout là est
vraiment mal placé pas ce qui me gêne
les pièces
j'aime les pièces noir même si je
comprends ils défendent et 5 mais du
coup c'est vraiment une pièce très
passive et du coup marc andry bas il a
une très très belle position à attendre
à huawei a affaire à valoriser tout
simplement ce qui me gêne un petit peu
c'est que il a 28 minutes autant yaris y
retrouve en difficulté autant il avait
traqué donc on espère que ça va pas lui
porter préjudice voilà c'est juste ça
qui est à surveiller sinon le reste
c'est très bien c'est sympa quoi voilà
donc
du coup ben on va on va continuer le
tour dans les études on veut je prie
d'aller voir notre ami m'hamed aller
hugo basse que mal évolué bon bah super
et la partie fight de la journée on
rappelle que madoff il a fait à une
nouveau enfin une nouveauté un coup
jamais joué à un haut niveau 3e coup est
du coup assez c'est assez c'est assez
étonnant ol a évolué sept cette position
et
si bien qu il nous fait quelque chose
d'assez malin qu'on voit dans les livres
c'est à dire il se sert du pion vous ne
rêvez pas le pion et bien blanc en
achète et plutôt que de le prendre
bêtement avec avec des noirs il s'en
sert pour
sécuriser son propre droit il le garde
parce que ça veut dire que les colonnes
peuvent - s'ouvrir
du coup c'est assez intelligent alors
être celle de la berri a fait chaud bah
oui cela est pris et la colonne achetant
qui va s'ouvrir
enverront elle fut pour se servir du
plan h7 adverse comme bouclier et
voilà donc du coup ce pion projetant bas
ils gênent les blancs les bleu et blanc
fracture h
est donc bon c'est celle où c'est une
manière de pouvoir se défendre contre
les attaques des blancs
mvl il mais participe à ce tournoi skype
est elle à vous avez envie de voir bella
malheureusement
également parce que les places sont
chères et
il ya aussi bas donc c'est un tournoi
qui se déroule en hollande il ya déjà
pas mal de place
enfin là il ya des places réservées
je sais pas pourquoi ils ont invité par
exemple grand delius pas qui est un
super joueur ce n'est pas le souci qui a
un jeu assez spectaculaire d'ailleurs
donc c'est comme un bon choix mais c'est
pas
c'est pas les way c'est pas le mail fait
pas partie du top 10 mondial en tout cas
donc est-ce que c'est des histoires
d'exigeant je crois pas à ma
connaissance que maxime est refusée
simplement qu'ils ont préféré inviter
d'autres joueurs il ya des accords des
machins des oueds et tractations pour
ses belles places
mais c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
dommage et firent au delà on sait que il
a refusé les conditions proposées voilà
je suis un problème l'an dernier on a
déjà raconté l'histoire faut aller voir
le replay sur la chaîne chasse com/fr si
vous le souhaitez et n'hésitez pas non
plus à vous abonner à la chaîne youtube
chess com/fr aussi comme ça vous aurez
toutes les infos en temps réel voilà
alors du coup alors on n'a pas tué le
petit point de pub alors donc vous savez
que kevin et moi on stream sur nos
chaînes respectives donc je vais vous
vous mettez pour faire un peu de pub là
dessus donc qui évite crois qu stream
cinq jours sur sept exact voilà bon pas
ce week-end parce que ce week-end je
suis bien pris avec toi se trouve donc
je fais une infidélité à mon créneau du
de 19h à 20h30 puisque je pense qu'on
sera toujours un stream de toute façon
voilà donc n'hésitez pas à découvrir la
chaîne et on se retrouvera de bas de
façon hebdomadaire mardi mercredi jeudi
et les soirées dès vendredi et dimanche
soir voilà voilà comment ça se passe
alors qu'à nice guy en train de pleurer
stouff quand on dit ça j'espère que
c'est pas parce qu'il va rater le
le stream de ce soir kim pleurs anish
giri je pense que c'est plutôt en lien
avec sa position mais voilà donc parce
que je pense que c'est en lien aux
tweets que va faire carlsen après après
sa victoire contre ighirri vous avez
deux joueurs ce bon ils s'aiment bien
ils sont ils sont amis à ma vraie vie
mais ils se frôlent l'un et l'autre
comme pas possible sur les réseaux
sociaux et s'il n'ya une victoire 21-16
je peux vous dire que le message va
partir comme ce serait le cas si
ce cas même pire je pense si eddy rythme
syrienne y
est filou bah tu dis que tu connais pas
encore peu t'inquiète pas ça viendra
donc voilà n'hésitez pas et on laisse le
faucon philosophe on laisse le flou et
tu vas voir c'est celle de qualité voilà
il faut la goulfie que faut pas hésiter
à aller découvrir nos chaînes
respectives et du coup se trouve ça fait
un moment qu'ils stream maintenant et du
coup vous vous le connaissez pour la
plupart mais en tout cas ce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas n'hésitez pas non plus à
les voir aller voir la chaîne ça nous
fera grand prix grand plaisir et où vous
retrouvera bas de manière hebdomadaire
avec tous les créneaux qu'on proposait
il ya des choses très variées et
normalement c'est fait pour vous pour
vous faire progresser et on échangera et
on passera des bons moments ensemble
voilà ce qu'on vous propose est due
cette position a énormément évolué
puisque elle était tout à fait
fantastique voyez encore leroy f1 qui
est bizarre mais elle commence à
ressembler à quelque chose de plus
classique
mais ce qui est un problème pour les
pour les blancs ce qu'on peut voir
clairement une manière visuellement ça
se gâte les blancs ils ont 00 centre
pourtant il a éveillé la première date
logique pour ramener le
le cavalier vers le centre fou au cices
et là elle a peut-être demander beaucoup
à sa position il a fait g6 et il aurait
peut-être dû se concentrer maintenant
sur le fait de
d'aller jouer au centre peut-être de
manière un peu plus naturel
tour d1 dames détroit faire le pressing
peut-être il a décidé que sa position
n'était peut-être pas si forte que ça et
il a voulu aller à la baston avec g6 et
la réaction hyper intéressante de
cipango
parce que c'est pas forcément le le coup
qu'on envisage en premier il s'est
développé naturellement en disant ben
vas-y tu me prends là je reprends du fou
j'ai pas de problème tu me prends achète
et là c'est le concept un classique
super je me cache derrière ton pions
voilà et du coup il n'ya pas y'a pas de
souci là-dessus
dame b 3 ok pression sur le pion des 5
et simplement d'hommes 17 ans dix ans
maintenant je me développe je me
développe naturellement hockey bombe à
la partie et est moins intéressant de
qu'au départ mais elle est encore très
prometteuse
et là on est
voit on voit les pendules à 40 minutes
vingt minutes on est dans le pré zai
note maintenant des clés les deux
joueurs vont attendre sous des vingt
minutes voire en dessous du quart
d'heure ça a commencé à bastonner et ça
pourra complètement complètement vrillé
voili voilou est-ce qu'on
est ce qu'on retourne voir manu ce que
je vois que c'est lui qui réfléchisse
parce que c'est nos deux parties
peut-être les plus les plus intéressants
de la journée à moins que tu ai repéré
autre chose stouff
ben c'est que la quarantaine c'est la
partie à voir parce que à prendre
peut-être on pourra les voir un peu ce
qui se passe et prague ça y est il est
gagnant par la scène j'ai vu la jauge d
ailleurs voilà la jauge vous indique
qu'il ya vraiment gros gros avantage
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
tourbes et inde 1 à 5 fu prend des 5e
prendrait cinq et on avait vu on s'était
précipitée sur la possibilité d'un même
5 au début me f6 donc car la scène lui
c'est surtout précipités surtout
reprendre cette
c5 a été jouée par anish giri la jauge
s'est envolé au bout du monde et là est
ce qu'on n'a pas le damas f5 justement
souffre dans les bonnes conditions
j'attaquais vii et sur m6 cette fois ci
j'ai quelque chose dans mon sac dames 2
g dames 17 caisses qui viendrait
d'un médecin qu'est ce que je peux je
tous réfutent l'idée d'avoir joué ses
cinq passes que je peux plus faire vous
prendre la tête du bloc le fou mais chez
lipp au caire m'a dit je préfère
cavaliers prendra sous faut garder ma
tour le cavalier lartigue il y avait
cavaliers à chis j'espère que ça marche
l'histoire pas le tout de faire du guil
il faut que ça marche pas sûr que ça
marche mon histoire parce que tu fais
juste roi je suis tu je suis deg faire
des guilis aguerris ouais voilà ont
franchement si un jour les échecs ça
nous dit plus ouf on pourra faire de la
poésie
parce qu'on est vraiment un fléau des
jeux de mots un ou des jeux de mots
voilà
bienvenus
à nous à la comédie française
voilà ses caniches a une chance
honnêtement ce zéro parce que c'est une
position qui pique les yeux là on peut
pas cacher que la barre vient de nous
indiquer que bon c'était une position
inadmissible et et du ku'damm f5 donne
envie mais attention on peut peut-être
que je peux jouer autre chose j'ai
cavaliers 1er set qui donne envie aussi
à calais g5 c'est pas mal attention
quand même aux seuls contre je dames 1
échec 3g de est peut-être tout reprendre
de donc il semble que j'ai tout intérêt
à garder pour le moment cavaliers 1,5
franchement dame f5 je pense que ces
deux coups gagnants et j'ai trouvé mieux
finalement stouff je suis fait une
petite une petite infidélité à d'amd
cette dame f5 f6 peut-être dame g4
encore un petit guily
tout l'art bien je pense que guy est
volée de marches sur l'attitude devant
l'échiquier je pense qu'il est à hilla a
rien d'abandonner oui oui c'est ça donc
d'amener les cinq ont été
forcées et comment on finit parce que
c'est important c'est pas le tout de
d'arriver dans cette position faut finir
le job
on va trouver on va trouver c'est clair
voilà donc des 9,5 a été jouée par
magnus
pas de souci et c'est derrière
aniche il a dû jouer touré fille de
tempo hockey
et c'est maintenant est ce qu'on va
trouver plus vite que magnus stuff
voilà il ya cavaliers prend effet ce
qu'est l'art bien il ya tour et c'était
l'arbitré qui avait les 17 qu'elle
arbore aussi beaucoup de coups il a tous
les coups doivent gagner mais nous on
veut finir le
finir le plus vite possible alors qu'à
et 17 hockey ça fait mal à tous réfutent
mais à la limite on peut presque le se
laisser croquer la tour f 8 en se disant
que je cours après je mange des 5 ouais
je pense qu'on peut là j'ai envie de
gagner j'ai envie de mater un j'ai envie
de mater
donc je regarde un film kf cette voie là
cavalier
qu'on avait envie de jouer mais j'ai pas
trouvé la suite à mon grand désespoir
parce que en fait j'ai proposé l'idée
que m6 vous voyez que sur g prend ainsi
adam prend à chaque échec et mat mais je
rate quelque chose sur cavaliers à chis
rouages suite et ça m'énerve parce qu'on
aurait trouvé bon damien proposé par
sous froid g2 d'impro eux deux est là on
doit on doit gagner à peut-être juste
odin prend des 5 et voilà le coup
silencieux
voilà je pense que ça y est
en fait magnus si d'ailleurs il va bien
il peut pas se laisser prendre les
quatre ont fait déjà plus de coups en
fait je crois que la menace de manu
c'est simplement d'apprendre et 5 avec
le matin à l'étouffée dit de lui sénat
qui est le matin à l'étouffée le plus
classique si je prends des cinq après je
menace un des plus esthétiques matt que
beaucoup de joueurs de clubs connaissent
si vous êtes joueur sur internet plutôt
débutants c'est assez rigolo ce qui se
passe après d'âpres en d5 il y aura
cavaliers à chis potentiel double échec
le roi est obligé de bouger dame g8 une
sorte de baiser de la mort ou la tour
peut prendre et on a fermé la case du
roi et maintenant je reviens en rêve
c'est de faire échec et mat maintenant
que le roi il est totalement cramer ici
coincé c'est terrible voilà voilà voilà
et là ça ferait c'est le matin c'est le
mat de deux routes 29-29 se passer si
les soldes ça tout à l'heure ils étaient
là je crois route et chez qui m'a envoyé
une partie d'autres fois sur surface
comme où il a fait un match à l'étouffée
qui peut le montrer en jour les pièces
alors ça vous aurait donc un effet dames
1 ce serait relativement logique roigé
de dame prend hélas je pense que damas
prendrait 5 et ultra fort je pense c'est
imparable donc on va jouer un coup
hasard juste parce que mon tour ouais
donc on va recaler c3 pour jouer le jeu
pour montrer que même à attaquer la dame
bah c'est pas terrible puisqu'il ya ka
voyagiste double échec rouages suite et
dames j'ai vite ça c'est le vraiment
quand on peut faire ça dans une partie
on est trop content donné sa dame c'est
pas très bons grecs général mais là il
ya une justification et c'est c'est fini
alors tentons en vendant ses coûts vite
d'un jack de demande sur nos pages aux
dames et 8 à la place de jaude cavale
c36 il a raison fictive lança contrôle a
case of 7 il a raison mais en fait tu as
raison et finalement tu vas voir une
mort lente parce que khaled et si je
gagne ta dam kovic du coup bah tu
apparais le matin c'était c'était
intelligent pour ça mais bon pour des
joueurs de ce niveau là ça revient
quasiment au même de se faire mater ou
de données saddam dans ces conditions là
donc malheureusement je crois que le
dame prend des cinq en fait c'est la
grosse menace et du coup après cavaliers
pro f 7 bat aniche il sait plus quoi
jouer et oui c'est
c'est la problématique de cette position
je suis sans coup et même de manger
lentement oui oui la manger avant
on venait de voir et du cou en fait j'ai
failli proposé c'est prendre des quatre
pour empêcher d'impro dessin il mais en
plus il ya même dame aussi si vous
voulez donc ça change rien non plus sur
ces prend des cas la tour f 800 r non
mais là je ne sais même pas comment il
va réussir à jouer un coup
mais là déjà et commencé à faire une
tête de peu nos on sentait que il
faisait pas le mac bella
lassé du rhin pour les mecs parce que
c'est des génies des échecs
franchement on sait que c'est douloureux
de perdre aux échecs
même nous aksu fin à notre niveau bas on
est ultra compétiteurs et quand on se
retrouve comme ça juste avant de perdre
c'est toujours des sensations qui sont
pas très bonnes un stuff on les aime pas
trop ses positions là donc je pense que
pour aniche surtout qu'ils se
connaissent bien et cetera
c'est bien quand on joue des potes et
qu'on gagne mais c'est pas bien quand on
perd et du coup c'est toujours dur
d'ailleurs de jouer des joueurs que l'on
connaît mais là haut niveau ils n'ont
pas le choix il se joue tout le temps
ils se connaissent tous il ya des
nouveaux venus à chaque fois au bout
d'un moment mais en tout cas balle à
aniche hisser qui va se la faire coller
mais il ya toujours de l'espoir aux
échecs même un haut niveau on a obligé
même si on a une petite chose sur samba
d'essayer sauf que là après cavaliers
pros f7
maniche l'a vu tout ce dont on parlait
des couches soit même pas un coup se
trouve en fait dans sa position parce
qu'haïti menace a proposé
menace d'en prendre et synchrones
l'amitié sous menace même des cavaliers
h6 qu'on adore ça s'était très tentant
karachi semés sur what she peut-être
qu'on n'avance pas assez
peut-être que maintenant maintenant à et
maintenant d'armandie série parce que
j'ai pas j'ai pas non plus et non parce
que radha besoin d'un point f2 attention
car on avait bien dit attention on avait
bien dit oh la petite pépite avec d'amd
de là ils donnent pas vraiment saddam
envoyer tous voilà il ya la dame en
l'air et du coup qu'est ce qu'il a prévu
sur dame six
dames 6 d'un v8 j'avais vu tours sète
donc du coup c'était pas si mal un
tour pro f cette non mais là c'est du
délire total je vais non mais en fait
d'un merci ça doit marcher et très bien
je pense
dame si ça peut être le coup de magnus
il va réfléchir un petit peu il a vu
d'un me 6
adam six dames f6 autant pour moi
maintenant il faut faire attention à ne
pas ne pas fauter vous avez vu j'ai
toujours mon double échec comme tout à
l'heure mais si je tourne le mat le même
match que tout à l'heure il y aura pas
mal puisque madame un f6 va se sacrifier
qu'on le retour du cavalière f7 donc là
je souhaiterais là c'est intéressant on
va chercher et on va trouver le gain ski
âgé 7 il ya beaucoup de choses en l'air
mais à nice il veut tenter d'ahmed 6
alors
maintenant faut être un tout petit peu
sérieux on a presque fait le job on va
clairement pas tout gâcher
d'amd 8 on n'avait pas vu cette défense
quand même on voit que voilà c'est un
joueur de très haut niveau donc il a de
la ressource
on va gagner c'est sûr on va gagner pas
du tout exprès mais il faut trouver le
moyen assez bien sûr si je suis un petit
faites vous la main tout le monde doit
chercher la tactique dans le chat vous
avez le droit aussi de trouver la
tactique avant nous hein alors dam des
huit petites résistances il suffit de
mettre une autre menace au au point et
à
je pense avoir trouvé un presque qu'un
tiens stouff je te propose de regarder
vos besoins je vais faire
dames 6
2006 damev 6 et d'un prendrait 5 mais je
suis pas sûr que ce soit si mon gars je
voulais faire le gain de patience il ya
peut-être cavaliers ces trois noms mais
j'ai tout reprendre cette non non tour
problème c'est que j'avais prévu tout
reprend f7 avec la torah 8 en l'air et
est ce que tu es mal hein
ouais ça mais en fait ça marche pas je
crois en plus ça marche mais
malheureusement d'en prendre 5 c'était
pour protéger mon cavalier f7 par
transparence c'est à dire je visais la
torah 8
d'aniche mais je suis pas sûr que ce
soit si malin dame si ce dernier six
dames 35 cavaliers c3 et je redonne du
jeu j'ai failli boire mon micro ce que
je me suis trop
attention du coup c'est pas situation si
magnus vous paraître tempo c'est que
c'est pas si facile ça doit être gagnant
j'ai pas je sais pas
je suis pas inquiet pour lui on sent que
c'est gagnant parce que
[Musique]
ouais on voit qu'on a tous les pièces
septième rangée et à tous les thèmes qui
sont là mais voyons galère mine de
ce qu'on peut voir simplement c'est que
déjà dans la position
les noirs en fait peut vraiment bougé du
tout et même par exemple des princes et
5 juin
ouais des processions coup c'est à 9,6
ouais prise prise qu'à voyage si ce
jeu suit
derrière trou un gain peu comme tu le
dis je trouve ça un gain de confort il
les aime bien les gains comme ça
sans se prendre la tête sera menée dans
une position gagnante de finale
mais on sent si vous voulez avec sauf
qu'il ya sûrement un gain clair ici on
aimerait bien de trouver
pourquoi on peut se permettre de dire ça
ce que vous voyez l'insécurité du roi
noir amène l'envi de tact y fier
l'adversaire
mais c'est pas si pas si simple cette
histoire quand même pareil ok mais bon
est blessé mais
carsen je pense que bon enfin il ne va
peut-être faire le coût de ce tout fin
je vois bien un petit des français 5 de
magnus tu sois tranquille pépère
possible alors la montre en
2006 d'un front des 5 oui mais goûteux
l'heure exacte alors il ya peut-être des
cavaliers pendant ces trois tons dames
promet m6 avec ses 6 mhz
je le trouvais sympa
on est en difficulté mais bon c'est
dommage de ne pas trouver un matou
quelque chose alors des fois c'est
frustrant les échecs ce mais ça fait
partie du jeu on galère à trouver le
gain
de recherche comme magnus à vous voyez
on n'est pas plus rapide que magnus qui
s'entend à stouff on voit là on veut pas
écoeurer magnus donc on fait semblant de
pas avoir trouvé avec stouff
alors
c'est pas facile il ya tous les thèmes
pourtant tout à l'air placé pour que ça
se passe et dans le chat on voit pas non
plus
on voit pas non plus de la folie
en fait le truc c'est que et d'un proche
est paulo toi tu étais gourmands
tu me proposes d'un projet de barreau
apprend et n'a pas gagné grand chose
même si tu prends la dame après on te
reprends ta rien gagné
du coup du coup du coup du coup
peut-être des princes et 5 on va aller
au plus simple des princes et 5 et on
reste
effectuez le pressing
une belle variantes par exemple qu'est
ce que ça peut être peut-être ça stouff
des princesses cinq tours b 8 je voyais
bien
c'était assez logique pour moi et c6 est
ce que j'ai le droit de jouer ça
c'est que l'avant dans l'idée un orange
moi je mange russe et tant que c'est pas
super simple à cinq jours parce que le
pion de tous fils va devenir monstrueux
quoi c'est que dès qu'ils arrivent en c6
c'est un éléphant quoi
alors dans le château me demande ce qui
va se passer après dépenser 5 en fait la
question c'est qu'est ce que les noirs
peuvent jour en fait on se rend compte
que les noirs n'ont pas beaucoup de
choses à faire le cavalier à 4 ne joues
pas tu auras but ne joue pas la dame
doit plus moi rester là pour défendre la
case des cinq on avait dit que d'amd 5
était une grosse menace
d'al f6 ne marche pas qu'aux de dame
prend des cinq ans l'a expliqué avec la
lah vis-à-vis entre la dame et le roi g8
et aussi avec le roi entre entre la rb5
et la tour à 8 sont élus qui avaient des
exemples sont comme des 5
imaginons ce que je devais aussi je
pense pouvoir un genre d'épreuve à saint
gilles a réussi juste pour voir on
montrait un petit peu d'emprunter 5 on
avait dit au pire des cas même tête d'un
point m6 est mieux
maîtrisée
et cavaliers h 10 avec ses 6
paraît déjà
attaqué à tour tour bouge j'ai même du
fou hausse est beaucoup de choses
regarde jean à tomber vite par exemple
on va voir juste pour voir on doit vite
être là je te faire
fawcett maintenant moi aussi
qui force plus les choses à mon goût un
ferme at là bas j'ai maté un la soupe en
six matches j'entends qu'un tour avant
je ne mange pas si c'est parce que la
tour j'ai celle qu'on le prend d'avoir
un bouclier donc tout reprend pions
prend attaque la torah 8 et quand la
tour bouge il faut quand même si ce
match
prendre ça c'est une menace pour arriver
à près de 9,6
ray terrible est en fait juste il ya des
réseaux mal de partout tu peux pas
bouger une pièce c'est un cauchemar et
dé prendre ça en fait c'est un coût qui
dit ok je trouve rien d'immédiat donc
jouer un coup qui va montrer un pion qui
est maire la pollution qui ouvre mon fou
et tout quoi
au prochain coup le pion c6 devient
presque une pièce quoi de cases de la
dame donc c'est vraiment malin des
français 5 on peut imaginer s'il fait un
autre groupe d'amis six cavaliers c3
et sajoo
c'est juste ok et six mois jeudi à new
york
sinon moi je te fuis
tu le pion est trop fort et cavaliers
prend 1 2 c'est qu'une maigre
consolation un jour roi g2 c'est ça une
pg c'est ça fait remonter le train de
marquer
ça commence à faire très très mal
moi j'essaie de la pause ont proposé par
stouff
alors j'ai foule 5-fu des six qui de
gagner je crois rêver au met la pression
sur ses terres la projection dans la
troisième 6 1 la mef six cavaliers
agissiez se croit g7
c'est si je disais tomber vite fawcett
est là sur roy g7 est de savoir ça fout
des six jours le projet s'est tous les
six ont failli échec a découverte s'ils
mangent date où je prends atteint 88 et
je fais dame prochain enfin parce qu'on
a ça et le pion qui va à dame et si le
bravo je vais avec fougue grand tour je
mange du fou juste pour te dire tu as
tour est le plus touché
c'est vite
ça c'est pas calculable
jusqu'à vallier
suroît justice je me charge et 4000
tient même
j4m pour montrer juste g4 en fait la
région cavaliers et tu peux pas ses
fruits a d'ailleurs pas non mais c'est
fini c'est terminé on va leur équipe et
leurs gardes mais bon d'accord il faut
calculer il faut voir ce qui se passe un
donc bonnes questions de victimes mais
mais voilà la pression à désespérer
magnus il n'a pas trouvé un peu bon
voilà on voit que c'est pas si facile en
fait on a l'impression que c'est foutu 1
mais elle n'a pas trouvé de choses
concrètes donc magnus il vient de jouer
des princes et 5 magnus et du khroub on
comprend on comprend pas ce que nous non
plus on n'a pas réussi à trouver de
gains clair donc c'est assez rigolo et
manu c'est typiquement son style
d'ailleurs de faire des coups comme ça
d'amélioration pour gagner propres et
c'est foutu c'est foutu après
après
oui son style mais enfin mais là c'est
l'exigence de la logiciel là tu as
raison on en match et là on voit que les
noirs sont tellement asphyxié poteau
manque rien faire il ramène le 1/3 la
fête qui participait pas trop en fait et
du coup c'est
terrible elle cavaliers à 4 toujours
aussi nul bref
mais matériellement tout sa fin puisque
là maintenant les noirs qui avait une
qualité plus aux deux pions maintenant
de moins donc un nouveau matériel les
blancs sont déjà organisés
non c'est vraiment
ce qu'on n'irait pas voir une autre
partie où tu veux rester là souffle en
plus bouger on va voir ac par exemple ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'est pas les rames
agv aller le petit jeune prague nalanda
qui se retrouve un peu en difficulté
autant duda lui met la pression par
contre
on voit que c'est plutôt
les blancs qui obtiennent un petit un
petit quelque chose un petit pressing
après est-ce que ça suffira ou non
pourquoi je me permets de dire ça parce
que les pièces sont plus actives chez
les blancs très clairement
non franchement c'est assez agréable à
jouer avec les blancs par contre je vois
cinéma l'autan ce qu'on explique pas si
facilement mais c'est peut-être pas si
facile non plus à jouer sur le long
terme en cas dé change d'âme les noirs
ont l'avantagé de dames
majorité elle dame qu'il pourrait faire
fructifier
mai
[Musique]
maintenant tout de suite on a on préfère
avoir les blancs parce que on a envie
d'attaquer d'amener la dame de fer des
petites choses sur la huitième le
problème c'est qu'il n'ya plus que trois
pièges chacun donc on est dans le cadre
d'une pré finale qui annonce la finale
on peut nier changer
les dames et
enfin ni les tours ni les dames est bien
sûr encore moins les dames comme je le
disais ça amènerait une finale un peu
désavantageuse donc doux dingues et il
attend un tapis dans l'ombre il a une
position de contre il aimerait bien je
pense profiter de l'erreur de du petit
jeune prague nalanda mais on peut dire
se trouve que ça une bonne tête de finir
en match nul quand même je sais pas ce
que tu en penses
ouais d'accord parce que des plans comme
celui là par exemple d'amener les pieds
ça l'a fait c'est pas facile il ya
toujours ce pion u15 qui n'est pas
soutenue et les pièces sont quand même
pas ridicule à damian que lecavalier
fils qui est bizarre messi joue tour des
huit viatour c8 et en plus ce cavalier
que je qualifie de bizarre il tient là
la septième rangée à tout moment ils
peuvent venir en 6 voire angers 6
quoique la dernière idée h4 c'est plutôt
de mal d'options à chaque pour éviter
cela
mais la position apparaît pas être grand
chose pour pour le joueur blanc donc on
est on est quand même assez pennarun n'y
a pas de
ouais y'a rien qui se passe on continue
petit tour des positions se trouvent
avant d'aller voir peut-être marque
andry
alors est ce tu veux on peut aller se
faire il ya eu 85 ch 47
on peut aller faire un tour chemin
randria avant de lâcher une
une page de pub d'accord
en bas de chaque chaque heure on doit
lancer une petite pub et moi on fait
comme ça on va voir la partie de marc
andré dont qui joue dans le tournoi b on
rappelle que c'est plus jeunes grands
maîtres français il détient le record
depuis peu de temps il vient de passer
grand maître il est 2503 si je dis pas
de bêtises et il a l'occasion de faire
le tata steel challenger qui est un
tournoi extrêmement fort
où il ya très peu de m les mettre c'est
vraiment des jeunes pousses très
prometteuses et du coup marc andré il
avait obtenu une position tout à fait
intéressant de tout à l'heure alors là
on voit que c'est un tout petit peu
moins bien ce qui s'est passé en
vérifier cela mais
tout cela il ya une position de pressing
on a envie envie de jouer cavalier f3
dans cette position est de travailler la
position en mettant un bloqueur en d4 il
a préféré prendre j'ai six reprises et
faire cavalier à 4 ce qu'il veut en fait
il a bien vu que son adversaire à un
pion isolé donc il veut échanger les
pièces tour à ses huit dames d un
d'accord et il a échangé les pièces ça
c'est très bien la problématique c'est
que maintenant attention l'adversaire
menace à terme des quatre îles à jouer
qui a laissé trois conventions sur des
kataëb et 5
son adversaire paraît maintenant assez
actif quand même et
visuellement ça paraît moins bien que
tout à l'heure
peut-être d'un médecin qui suit avec
baignoire pour mettre le pressing sur
les pions pme sont
en fait des noirs voudrait faire des cas
tout le temps ou encore le peur
voilà vingt-cinq menacent eux quatre
menaces des quatre du coup ouais puis je
suis en action sur b2 voyage trop
cavalier aussi virtuellement beau jeu
cavalli parce que nous ce qu'on veut
faire c'est mettre ici au mali est notre
candidat il a empêché trois ans que je
proposais
mais nous trouvons voulais faire c'est
mettre un cavalier en vue des quatre ans
serait la position idéale
mais du coup le pion mais de temps prise
donc c'est un peu compliqué à faire pour
l'instant peut-être on peut le faire
avec pour message mais j'y crois pas
trop
pardon en vieux briscard où j'aime bien
me 5 pour tu vois pouvoir toujours
pareil venir autrement avant le zaï note
tu vois commencé à venir dire bonjour au
roi il y avait une autre idée un peu
plus fantasques jeu mais madame ou 5
elle est souple un peu partout elle est
là et là en même temps et il y avait je
n'ai pas oublié cette petite idée là
peut-être qu'ils pouvaient qui pourrait
être assez destructrice en fait dans
cette position c'est assez rigolo bon il
a préféré d'imbéciles et grand maître il
est de 1650 on va lui faire confiance il
a mis la pression après si vous voulez
dans des positions comme ça du jeu de
construction il n'y a pas de gains
tactiques réel il ya des fois plusieurs
coûts potentiels et les deux était
intéressant à mon sens
ouais
ok donc la marque andré là une position
intéressante mais loin d'être gagnante
gérer un tout petit plus à faire
fructifier
est ce que tu as envie qu'on aille voir
crainte est un petit moment à voir sans
pub patron voit que lionel roux la chute
on avait peur et pronostiqué on va aller
voir ça avant de vous laisser alors hop
cela je pense qu'il va m'emmener bien de
tout guérir
et voilà en fait il a transposé dans une
variante assez simple
donc il a bien fait des princes et 5
d'un 9,6 pour l'anti jeu avec le
matériel davance sauf que là le matériel
d'avancement ne suffit pas parce que les
pièces ne sont pas assez active donc
cavalier agissent pour pas perdre le
cavalier roi suite et on valorise
maintenant qu'ils ont de plus le pion le
pion passé pardon
donc on a un pion pour la qualité dans
deux pions pour la qualité c'est énorme
donc c'est immatériel est en fait la ya
trop de menaces donc sur tours fc 8
c'est assez c'est assez logique faut en
faire encore un petit effort
ce que la cij ou fawcett vous voyez tout
ce
que ce roi g7 j'ai pas le coup tout à
l'heure de fous des 6 et 7 et les tours
sont mortes le cavalier est au bord
voilà ça va se finir dans pas longtemps
on va voir ça arrive et où ça arrivait
suroît g7 maintenant il devrait y avoir
cavaliers l5 avaler des 6 km de cette
voie là donc ice age 3 c'est normal avec
cette idée là des cavaliers cette gamme
tempo voilà et on va assister bientôt à
cavaliers affichent des six par exemple
un abandon pas se quereller f7 wabush 5
avril et des six
français huit tours prend
way sur cavaliers sont en cavale et
bessin moi je prends une tour tour
prends tu bouges je viens quand on sait
cette attention non mais ça gagne en
ligne je pensais
alors comment vous fait pour gagner
un peu de passion aussi on n'a pas
pas de grosse pression ici
on pourrait même faire food & cie ce
qu'on serait pas malin avec cavaliers b
5 vous justifiez f4 et ça gagne aussi 1
déjà en fait tous gagnent tout gagner on
veut le truc le plus réglo
le plus tranquille
cavaliers f700 game tempo roi g8 je
prèfère ou non crois j'essais de pardon
cavaliers des six cavaliers b5 sur le
coup quasiment
mais là
bas on apporte du gain
juste un petit peu précis
toujours une galère vous voyez que même
la bête blessée donc à nice guy riba il
s'accroche et et finalement pour le
finir c'est pas si facile et qu'est ce
qu'on dirait de fou b2
pas regarder foulée deux ex trouve pour
l'instant
il faut b2c un joli coup je crois
ou de roy g7 je pense
oui mais était tour comme elles peuvent
plus bouger je prends en c3 et voilà je
joue le coup à magnus c'est bien ça veut
dire que j'ai eu je peux faire le
tatarstan soyez un coup sûr un coût
c'est même et sur walf du cavaliere
chacun 100 points en plus
et là aussi partie d'un stylet sur un
coup ya eu 10 4 à descartes il affiche
avec art gallery a
dit je pense et du coup y'a plus
problème de
banques avec des sacs
parce que je mange ses 8
on s intéresse encore de faire cavalier
b5 ce qui va faire ne sont pas le choix
tout ça sans ces termine à dos
à ski ou tel juste mon genre ces huit
mangeant c8 et jouer un coup et quand tu
commences à cet égard qu'au bout de
quatre
mois il peut jouer peut jouer à quatre
fins là c'est maintenant de plus en plus
en hollande très cher
bon ça va être la femme la partie là oui
c'est pour ça qu'on vous garde un petit
peu mais on
maintenant on peut l'annoncer
sauf séisme
victoire de magnus parce que là on voit
bien le la problématique qui est ici qu
on perd la partie tout de suite un
cavani v5 va être rejoué
vraisemblablement et on va prendre à
tout reprendre la tour à 4 par exemple
pour taper le
pour taper le carré dubé 5l pions des
cartes va tomber sa fredj adoption
maintenant faut vais juste vérifier
qu'on n'est pas encore mieux
en plus des atouts qui va tomber parce
qu'après il est le plus réussi ce qui
est faible plus rester ce qui est faible
et les pions restant des noirs comme 10
toof très bonne remarque on est que sur
des pions des gueux quoi donc là on a
deux pions de moi
voilà c'est me
on est aux portes ce même dingue dingue
un clerc vraisemblablement dans cette
position c'est-à-dire un gain direct
dans le gall direct le soir peu avant
elle de plus en plus je pense et c'est
sympa mais j'ai pas trouvé mieux
maintenant
il doit être assez désabusé hans vriens
partir pour une souffrance
ou est longue et sans espoir parce qu'on
sait que magnus un gros gros terre et
techniciens mais il faut jouer parce
qu'il ya toujours de l'espoir justement
même s'il est infime mais là c'est trop
dur 3030 à la pendule
vocalink
40 semaines il a franchement une belle
attitude ça me rappelle aux matchs pour
que l'epo en fait
bah il reste appliqué il est gagnant
c'est clair mais il continue à prendre
son temps infléchie oui très sérieuses
un modèle de toute façon
on peut vraiment le site et à chaque
fois en exemple alors que c'est le
numéro un mondial
trans il pas de souci je
veux qu'elle propose est qu aux écailles
bessac les cavaliers f5 de proposer avec
à et prend des quatre
oui donc fou fou fou b de là je pense
pas qu'il va aller en deux un bien sûr
c'est pas trop de
d'objectifs derrière ça va être trop
trop trop dur ok on peut peut-être
lancer la pub le temps que aniche
il ya des fêtes yes
ça marche elle est de suite les gens on
vous dit on vous dira tout de suite je
vous laisse avec ces chics et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ou une vue d'ensemble à l
échiquier c'est mieux là
bas sinon tu peux trouver
dans
[Musique]
commercial avec un tel
est l'appel de suffisante
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
à
et on est reparti voilà on va faire un
petit tour sur les scores puisque vous
voyez apparaître ben magnus qui l'a
confirmé et il a forcé l'abandon d'un
niche qui rit dans cette position
puisqu'il ya deux pions de plus le fond
qu'ils dominent totalement le cavalier
et du coup à aniche il a déposé les
armes forcément grosse partie de magnus
et défaite douloureuse quand même en
début de tournoi pour un nigiri qui a
pas vu trop le jour dans cette partie ce
qui s'est retrouvé rapidement en grande
difficulté lorsqu'il a gaffé avec avec
les dessins qu'il avait vraiment une
solution pour pour tenir il n'a pas
trouvé donc on voit qu'il y avait eu
deux nuls rapide il ya aussi la nulle
2 mamediarov et tsypko dans la partie la
plus complexe
de cette journée on peut dire ça comme
ça puisque je vous rappelle qu'il y
avait eu vraiment un début hyper
fantasque donc on va pouvoir aller
regarder avec avec stouff bac comment ça
s'est passé
7 nuls et ensuite on va pouvoir regarder
les trois i'm not
des parties entre sam champlan denis
legrand delius richard rapporte et
jordan forest trachman honda et ian
christophe duda et va-t-il y avoir un
seul de gagner dans ces trois partis ont
voulu rappelle il ya nos deux poulains
qui sont représentés donc
potentiellement du ce ballet gagner ou
du seuil bas perdre ça dépend comment on
se place souffle mais on va voir ça moi
je pense l'avoir l'habitude de perdre
mes soeurs s'inquiètent donc ça serait
ok barney reparti alors j'ai envie
d'aller voir la partie entre mamediarov
et et comment dirais-je
et son adversaire épisode ça fait nul
hein j'ai vu je veux juste savoir
comment d'accord ouais pour juste rapido
parce qu'on n'avait pas prédit nul
forcément je rappelle qu'il ya quelques
coups on disait qu'on a commencé à bien
aimé a bien aimé les noirs et sur la
dame b3 pas là la position était
vraiment intéressante il ya peut-être
des trois fines et c'est assez compliqué
la jouer dame 17 et ce serait vraiment à
plagne et à partir de deux dames 17 où
il ya eu proposition d'antijeu de
mamediarov qui est qui s'est dit bon
c'est bon j'arrête mes bêtises
[Musique]
j'avais une position très intéressante
tout à l'heure mais maintenant on voit
que c'est une position plutôt égal
et apparemment il ya eu un raté des
piscines kodo qui sont ils ont partagé
le point dans cette position qui est qui
est assez égal et jeu juste revenir sur
un moment dans cette position dame b 3
on voyait que la jauge était énorme
alors qu'est ce qu'ils auraient dû jouer
moi il y avait rien de facile en tout
cas clairement dans le 17 c'était pas le
choix du combat mais
ça c'est très dur par contre faire des
coups comme food et 6 pour garder garder
la pression et est peut-être menacé des
dames f6 et cetera tout pouvait se jouer
à ce moment là en tout cas et si bien qu
il manquait de temps aussi donc c'était
assez dur de jouer tous les bons coups
je pense que les deux finalement se
retrouvent content du partage de points
épisode qu il avait souffert dans le
début de partie mais a trouvé des
ressources et aimé y aura finalement a
vu une belle opposition se dresser face
à lui de la part des six penco et du
coup un finalement il était à la fin
content du partage du point je pense
mais mamediarov est si plein go se
retrouvent à égalité avec un point sur
deux et deux nuls mamediarov est très
ambitieux dans ce tournoi on l'a vu avec
deux parties
qui était quand même assez jolis seins
lors de ses deux premières rondes ok on
va on va aller voir ce qui reste
du coup ce serait dur si j'allais voir
mon poulain pour stouff mais en même
temps je vais pas aller voir le poulain
de souffle non je vais choisir une autre
partie c'est le bonheur d'avoir la main
en fait j'ai vu
grands débuts ce faire la faire la tête
et non un petit peu ce qui se passe et
du coup il n'avait pas l'air confiant
dans sa position alors que tout à
l'heure on avait dit qu'ils auraient
peut-être d achat cash 4 mai le roi ne
s'est pas fait avoir et maintenant il
n'y aura pas h4 stouff un ouais donc là
peut-être un petit canal et des 5 celui
de 2004 peut être pas mal centralisé un
peu les pièces surface blanche sur la
couleur inverse du ou des noirs et a
pressé de rentrer à la colonne b pour
les blancs donc une bonne position pour
probablement pour presser un petit peu
on voit de la taxe noir n'est pas
vraiment abouti à un plan isolé ans en
cinq ans c'est ça qui peut être faible
le pion h5 qui a été poussé de cool
purgé six est affaiblie depuis 11h ne
n'arrivera jamais en h4 est venu deux
fois ça aurait la tâche pour les blancs
achats
non vraiment une position très agréable
à jeu pour les blancs donc tout voici ce
qu'en disait en début de partie quand
les noirs ont joué f4 et n'auront réussi
à pousser on disait que les noirs
étaient vraiment leur zone de confort
parce qu'une potion d'attac etc mais que
s'ils attaquent la boulie sais pas eh
ben les blancs avaient même pas mal de
jeux sur l'île d'arz et là c'est en
france de produits en wac l'attaquent
des noirs finalement n'a pas ça n'a pas
réellement abouti et la pollution qui
est assez difficile et on rappelle que
les deux joueurs ils ont zéro donc
malheur au vaincu
dans cette danse est parti et sam
champions il a une petite option sur la
partie faut pas qu'ils h 11 minutes
contre dix minutes ça va être décisif et
évidemment
la vingtaine de minutes qui est à suivre
ça va être le moment chaud pour pour
tout le monde les nôtres vont arriver et
tout peut se passer
mais la position de 500 claude a l'air
assez stable du coup on peut se dire
qu'il va réussir à convertir cela petit
à petit on va voir tout rejet des 1
c'est le coup
c'était le coût attendu et du coup on va
on va commencer à voir la technicisation
est-ce qu'on n'irait pas voir entre
notre petit français qui donne sur un
nul ah
ok bon ben on va nous faire du la
répétition en fait je croquais dam des
six cavaliers à 4 cavale et cette fois
je pense que c'est c'était assez logique
dans un certain sens ne pas prendre trop
de risques après avoir perdu hier pour
se mettre bien dans le tournoi on va
aller voir effectivement on va débriefer
ça rapidement donc d'un bep si c'était
un pseudo coup malin dans un certain
sens après cavaliers à quatre dames des
six on va dire qu'il ya une
proposition nul implicite de la part de
marc andry
et du coup bah voilà
zuma by f
il s'est dit qu'il n'avait pas besoin
forcément de force et de cette position
avec les noirs c'est lui qui a le pion
isoler au niveau du temps il n'est pas
mieux que mark andry donc pas de raison
de d'aller prendre des risques
inutile avec les noirs et il préfère
avoir les blancs tranquillement demain
moi je vous rappelle que j'avais proposé
de dâm sen j'aimerais bien voir alors
dit est ce que ça se jouer ah oui en
fait l'ordi au premier coup il propose
g5 g4 propose et madame st qui est cette
idée g5 g4 qui me semblait prometteuse
et sur 2005 direct pas vraiment il
n'aime pas trop ah ouais c'était
intéressant dans le cinq l'acca et des
cinq ehpad à fond et 2 que des cavaliers
des six mois oui en gros cela c'est un
sa force à
faire cette position non c'était
vraiment intéressant à jouer parce que
les pièces blanches un peu bizarre
la belgique est du coup peut-être qu'à
et des cats là c'est évident et qui
avait les médecins de venir en d4 aux
questions directes et gt4 voir si je
peux faire inscrire si je mange je sais
pas chez l'idée g3 c'est pour ça que à
chaque fois c'est l'ange bleu c'est
dangereux de seringes cadre
oui peut-être en fait le mieux je
regrette un petit peu c'est être joués
g5 direct
comme ça sur calais b 5 peut-être que je
peux jouer dame b 6 août à wow ça a
l'air assez équivalent nommé la lavande
là comme saddam hussein a et b 5 g 5 k
et des cats je trouve que c'était pas
mal qu'on va essayer de mettre la
pression avec les noirs g4 n'y a rien de
fait un mais si on veut gagner en tout
cas vague les noirs fallait tenter cela
je pense que le grand maître il était
content aussi de faire nul avec avec les
noirs djoumabaïev
38 c'est un joueur très très dangereux
donc voilà avec le noir bon résultat
pour les deux joueurs je pense que pour
marc-andré il a et bat tous les jours
c'est des joueurs
2630 deux fois donc des très forts
grands maîtres qu'il a joué là ils
allaient blanc s'ils venaient à perdre
il démarrait à 0 sur deux donc c'est
toujours dur psychologiquement il sait
qu'il aura pas de route de repos donc là
ok il prend une demi point et maintenant
c'est parti il va pouvoir se lâcher dans
dans le tournoi
alors salut photo mode ou photos
la tour baudet forme et moyen le fat ou
moyen fatou
[Musique]
je craque un petit peu en fin de fin
mais c'est normal tu as bien donné tu as
bien donner ce tout fait du coup va
retourner on va retourner dans le a5 on
va voir le collège s'est fait un petit
plaisir on va voir panananda le poulain
de stouff oh la la eh ben on va assister
prochainement à la nulle puisque là
c'est en train de s'équilibrer wiba
cavaliers prend 1 500 manquent pas j'ai
quand même vous mettre les la bonne came
est sûre qu'elle va les prendre 5 je
pense qu'on va avoir droit adam points 5
passes et surtout reprendre 5 il
pourrait y avoir d'un handicap qui
pourrait poser quelques petits soucis
sur le plan b 6 sur le clouage à
l'endroit et la tour
donc dimpre entourant et ça va faire nul
on est très tôt on avait instigué nul 1
voix là très tôt et du coup ben c'était
ce qu'avait recherché jan christoph duda
prague lalande a vraiment essayé de
jouer et de poser des petits problèmes
bon je crois qu'en fait
malgré sa volonté il n'y a pas eu de
problèmes mais ça a été assez ça a été à
ceux assez rapide
7 7 nuls à se mettre en place y a pas eu
de gros problèmes de grosse réflexion
on voir à gourdon peut-être son premier
grand grand tournoi qui calment fait nul
avec guérini le rythme d'un tous de
pratiquer